NO RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
IN HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS AND ALL PURCHASES IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE WOULD
MEAN MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOWING WILL BE
USING TELECONFERENCE SERVICES
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND
MISTRUST FOR REMOTELY TODAY
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT TO
SPEND TOLL FREE NUMBER ACCESS
CODES POSTED ARE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WILL ALSO BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN I WILL NOW SIT
NOW REYES BECAUSE THE NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE
ONE ONE FOUR ZERO FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE TELECOM
SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE REFER
TO THIS ISSUE -- COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY
MODERATE DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
PRESS IS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER
WHICH MAY TAKE A MOMENT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE
MATTER TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER
THAT TIME YOU'LL BE ON MUTE
AND YOU'LL BE READY TO DRESS
THE COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
DEVOID CLOSE THE FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING OR LISTENING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING IS
THIS CUSTOMER AND AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTED MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OKAY THIS CONNECTIONS NEEDED
BOB BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION
OF BILLS WITH THE STATE WAS
CORMAN CHIEF COUNSEL PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM HOMBURG HI
HILLS AMBER GETS HERE FORTUS
PORTIS'S PRESENT DID ALSO
I'M SORRY -- GONZALEZ HERE
GONZALEZ IS HERE HERTZBERG JONES
JONES IS HERE LAYARD HERE
WHERE IT IS HERE MCGUIRE
STERN BY CAL SKI
WIENER WIENER SENATE WINNERS
PRESENT YOU HAVE A QUORUM THANK
YOU WE'LL HAVE SIXTEEN BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA WITH NIGHT
ON CONSENT THE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ARE AS FOLLOWS
FILE NUMBER TWO S. B. ONE THREE
NINE FOUR BY SENATOR EGGMAN
FOLLOW NUMBER THREE SB ONE ZERO
NINE SIX PERCENT OF THE MONTH
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB ONE
TWO ZERO TWO BY SAN RAMON FROM
NUMBER FIVE S. B. NINE THREE
FIVE PERCENT OR MIN FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN S. THREE NINE
THREE SEVEN BY SEVERAL TROUBLED
FROM NUMBER TEN S. B. NINE FOUR
SIX FOUR SEVEN JONES FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN S. B. NINE FIVE
SIX PERCENT WHITE KELSEY FIVE
NUMBER FOURTEEN S. B. ONE ZERO
ZERO FIVE PERCENT WHITE HOUSE
CAN FINALLY WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN S. B. EIGHT SEVEN NINE
BY SENATOR WIENER I DO MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SOME OF
SADDAM LAYERED MOVES THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- WITHOUT CALL THE
ROLL THE CONSENT COUNTERMEASURE
COUNCIL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SURE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
I'M BURKE -- BURKE HI BORJAS
FORGES I DO WRESTLE GONZALEZ
HI GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
JONES JONES I A LAYERED
LAYERED I'M MCGUIRE STERN
BY CAL SKI WIENER
WIENER AYE -- SO FAR YOU HAVE
SIX TWO ZERO OUR MEMBERS
OUT ON CALL OKAY HI I SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
HERE SO IS SUMMER WEEKS
ALSO GOING TO BE PRESENTING
ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
S. B. EXCUSE ME AB
TWO ONE SEVEN NINE
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE WHICH WILL EXTEND
EVICTION PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS
WHO HAVE FILED FOR EMERGENCY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE BY THE END OF
THIS MONTH SINCE THE RATE REALLY
PROGRAM LAUNCHED ONE YEAR AGO
CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE NATION IN
DELIVERING ASSISTANCE TO THOSE
MOST IN NEED AND AT RISK OF
LOSING THEIR HOUSING THE STATE
PROGRAM HAS DELIVERED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN DIRECT ASSISTANCE
TO DATE HELPING MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN THOUSAND
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS PAY OFF
RENTAL DEBT AND AVOID EVICTION
ONE IN THREE PAYMENTS NATIONALLY
HAVE BEEN MADE IN CALIFORNIA
TO TENANTS AND LANDLORDS THAT
ARE IN NEED BUT IT IS TAKING
LONGER THAN EXPECTED FOR THE
STATE TO PROCESS APPLICATIONS
FOR COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE THOUSANDS
AND THAT IS THOUSANDS CONTINUE
TO WAIT FOR RELIEF WHILE THEIR
APPLICATIONS AND IT WOULD BE
CRUEL IT WOULD BE WASTEFUL
AND EVEN UNFAIR TO SUBJECT
CALIFORNIANS TO EVICTION OR
THE LOSS OF RENTAL INCOME NOW
WHEN THEY HAVE DONE EVERYTHING
THAT IT'S BEEN ASK OF THEM AND
DISTRIBUTION OF THEIR EMERGENCY
ROOM RENTAL ASSISTANCE IS
EMINEM WE'RE NOT GOING TO ALLOW
FOR CALIFORNIANS TO SUFFER TO
LOSE THEIR HOMES OR EVEN THEIR
INCOME BECAUSE OF APPLICATION
PROCESSING TIMES AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE IS GOING TO HELP
US TAKE CARE OF THE THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS ALIKE WHO APPLIED
FOR COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND STILL
HAVE THEIR APPLICATIONS PENDING
THIS WILL HELP US AND LET US
MAXIMIZE EVERY LAST EMERGENCY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE DOLLAR TO
KEEP PEOPLE HOUSE EVEN AS
THE PROGRAM COMES TO AN END
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON I UNDERSTAND THAT --
WE HAVE --
-- WHITNEY PROUT AS WELL
AS FAITH CALMLY HERE TO TESTIFY
IS THAT CORRECT I BELIEVE
THAT IS CORRECT ALL RIGHT
THE MISTRIAL YES GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEHDI AT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT WOULD BE PROUD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IS THE LARGEST
STATEWIDE RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN THE NATION I
DON'T WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
THE LARGEST SEGMENT OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP OUR SMALL MOM AND
POP OWNERS THAT HAVE JUST A
FEW UNITS WE APPRECIATE THE
NARROW APPROACH TAKEN BY AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE IT
WILL PROTECT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE SUBMITTED RENTAL
ASSISTANCE APPLICATIONS BY MARCH
THIRTY FIRST WHILE CONTINUING
TO PROVIDE FOR STATEWIDE
CONSISTENCY AS THOSE FUNDS ARE
DISTRIBUTED JUSTICE CURRENT
LAW DOES THIS IS IMPORTANT TO
THE RENTAL HOUSING INDUSTRY AND
WE THANK YOU FOR MOVING THIS
LEGISLATION FORWARD THANK YOU
THE SPROUT -- I BEFORE MISS
CONNELLY TESTIFIES I SHOULD
NOTE THAT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
AND CLEANING PROTOCOLS I'VE
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY IT SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED TO WITNESSES WILL BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES
WHICH YOU'VE ALREADY OBSERVERS
PROP THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THE NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE OUR FAMILY
THANK YOU FIFTH COMING WITH L.
A. COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
FOR IN A BIT OF A TWEENER
POSITION HERE AND I THINK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY DO YOU WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS FOR THEIR COMMITMENT
TO THE PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL I WANT TO
MENTION THAT L. A. COUNTY HAS
PUT IN A REALLY FOUGHT FULL TWO
PHASE RAMP DOWN PROCESS OF THE
HIGHER PROTECTIONS THAT WE HAVE
WITHIN THE COUNTY AND AT THAT
PROCESS STARTS ON APRIL FIRST
AND WITHOUT THOSE PROTECTIONS
IN PLACE WE ARE VERY FEARFUL
THAT THERE WILL BE A THREE
MONTH WINDOW WHERE EVICTIONS
WILL START HAPPENING AND THE
PROTECTIONS WILL NOT APPLY TO
THEM IN THE COUNTY WE WOULD
URGE THIS COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
REMOVING THE LOCAL PREEMPTION
TODAY -- BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU CAN
THANK YOU MISS CONNELLY ALL
RIGHT OTHERS WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IN THE HEARING ROOM
SAYING MULLIN APPROACHING THEM
MIKE -- MODERATOR
IF THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS QUEUED
UP -- IF YOU COULD QUEUE THEM
UP WHO IS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO ONE SEVEN NINE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU AREN'T SUPPORT OF AB
ONE SEVEN NINE FIVE ONE
NINE ZERO YOUR HONOR YOUR
PHONE PLEASE PICK UP YOUR
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING
THE NUMBER ONCE AGAIN THAT
IN SUPPORT ONE SEVEN ZERO
WE WILL START WITH LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THE NEW GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
YOU HEAR ME I WAS YES WE CAN
ALL RIGHT -- GOOD EVENING
GOOD AFTERNOON ACTUALLY MY
NAME HELLO ACTUALLY CALLING
AGAIN EIGHTY TWO ONE NINE
I WOULD DEFINE LINE ITEM I'M
HAPPY TO GIVE MY COMMENT NOW
ALL RIGHT WELL LET'S WE'RE
GONNA TAKE THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT FIRST AND THEN WE'LL
TURNED OPPOSITION SO --
MATTER IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF TECH AND
SHE GOES BACK TO THE QUEUE
IF YOU AREN'T SUPPORTED
ONE ZERO THAT IS IN
SUPPORT BY NUMBER THIRTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS RYAN AND I AM
ALSO CALLING AND OPPOSITION
TO LOCAL PREEMPTION SO
I CANCELED MY COMMENTS
THE PEOPLE OF IRAQ YEAH
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
-- THOSE IN SUPPORT
RIGHT NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HEARING CONSULTANT WITH THE
RUNNING PUBLIC POLICY GROUP
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF MOUNTAIN VIEW IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE WILL GO TO LINE
AT NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MORE TOP OF
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THE RIVER TWO LINE NUMBER
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
HI THIS IS RENOVATION FONG
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSING
NOW COALITION I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE ONLY IF IT IS AMENDED
FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROTECT
THEIR OWN RESIDENTS REDUCTION
IN FRONT HOMELESSNESS ALSO
WE SEEING THAT ALREADY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE
COSTS MONEY ALL RIGHT NEXT
WHY NUMBER FORTY SIX ALL
HAD GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MORE KOLINSKI FOR THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
BY NUMBER FIFTY ONE
MICHAEL RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU WATER IT IF YOU
COULD ESTIMATE HOW MANY ARE INTO
THE TESTIFIED SUPPORT I'D BE
GRATEFUL WE DO HAVE
TWO LEFT IN THE QUEUE NOW FOR
SUPPORT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
BY NUMBER FIFTEEN
HI MY NAME IS WHAT IF YOU'RE
NOT FROM PEOPLE I AM IN SUPPORT
WE WILL GO NEXT JULY
NUMBER TWENTY SIX
ONE THING WAS DIRECTOR
TENANTS TOGETHER REPRESENTING
DIFFERENT GROUPS ONLY
SUPPORTS A FREE OPTION IT
REMOVED THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN
SUPPORT ON THE LINE ALL RIGHT
LET'S NOT TURNED OPPOSITION
THE SAME RULES APPLY TO
THE OPPOSITION IS APPLIED
TO THE SUPPORT I BELIEVE
WE HAVE KATE BELL ONLINE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
YES GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE
CHAIR NUMBERS KL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF GREATER LOS
ANGELES YOU MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE YET ANOTHER EFFORT
TO EXTEND THE ADDICTION
MORATORIUM'S GALLERY CARE
PRESENTS OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND MEMBERS TOTALING MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND RENTAL UNITS
IN THE STATE THEY'RE MADE UP
PRIMARILY OF SMALL AND MEDIUM
SIZED RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS
MANY OF WHOM HAVE CONTINUED
TO HELP TENANTS WITH NO
RENTAL INCOME AND NO RELIEF
IF OWNERS RELY ON THE INCOME
TO PAY MORTGAGES THAT HAVE
BEEN FINANCIALLY BURDENED BY
THE ELECTION MORATORIUM MUCH
MORE THAN CORPORATE OWNERS
CALORIEKING APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF PREEMPTION THE
BILL AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE AN ADVOCATE FOR MORE RENT
ASSISTANCE IN THE STATE I
BELIEVE IN AFFECTION MORATORIUM
HAS BEEN IN PLACE FOR LONG
ENOUGH THE PARAMEDIC OF THE
GRAPHENE THE STATE HAS RE
OPENED RESIDENTS HAVE ALREADY
HAD A YEAR TO APPLY FOR AN
ATV HAS HAD MANY MONTHS TO
PROCESS APPLICATIONS EXTENDING
EVICTION MORATORIUM BECAUSE
OF ADMINISTRATIVE DELAYS
CONTINUE WITH THE FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON OUR MEMBERS AND
FOR THAT REASON TOLERATE J.
AN ATLAS RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISSPELLED
OF OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THE PRESIDENT FOR
ON THE PHONE I SEE NO ONE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONES ARE
ALL RIGHT MADAME MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE
ON THE LINE IN OPPOSITION
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OF
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE THE
THE FIRST ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE OPPOSITION
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE THIRTEEN
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEXANDER HARDIN
WITH THE INNER CITY LAW CENTER
WE'RE EXTREMELY WORRIED ABOUT
RECKLESS STANCE AND THAT WILL
REPEAL PROTECTIONS FOR OVER
FOUR MILLION TENANTS BUT NOT
TIME TO GET THE WORD OUT TAKING
THEM DIRECTLY INTO A SECTION OF
HOMELESSNESS THANK YOU THANK YOU
LOS BY NUMBER EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO MY NAME IS MOHAMMED ALI
AND I'M A HEALTHY ACTIVISM TO
SKILLS I OPPOSE THIS BILL HAS
WRITTEN A FICTION PROTECTION
LOCAL VETERAN PRODUCTION
COMMITTEE NOT BE PREEMPTED
SO THOSE MUST BE THOSE AND
LOCAL PARK THANK YOU SIR ON
THE BILL NEVADA MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD GO TO THE NEXT
-- NEXT PERSON OPPOSITION
BY NUMBER THIRTY NINE
YOUR CARE MEMBERS HAVE RAIL
THERE AND READ THE SOCIO
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
BY NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
HE IS ACTIVE GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M A LEVEL FIFTEEN
I'M NOT REVENUE GLENDALE
CALIFORNIANS WORKING THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES I'M NOT A MEMBER
OF THE HOUSE I'M AGAINST IT
BECAUSE IT PREEMPT STRONGER
L. A. COUNTY PROTECTION
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TO MA'AM
AND THAT THAT ARE THANK YOU
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
WE HAVE Y. NUMBER THIRTY ONE
HELLO MY NAME IS CAITLYN CRACK
IN THE NATION AND I WORK WITH
STRATEGIC ACTIONS ARE JUST THE
KANEMI AND LOS ANGELES WHERE
WE SUPPORT LINE CONTRACT AND
THAT AND THEN WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS WRITTEN YES HELLO
WITH THE PREEMPTION OF BARLOW
FULL DETECTION THANK YOU
THIS IS PART IN OPPOSITION
IF ONE MAN HERO AND WE
HAVE LIKE NUMBER FORTY FIVE
ME YES YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN FORTY
FOUR HELLO THANK YOU YEAH MY
NAME IS GENEVIEVE FULLER AND
AREA RESIDENTS CALLING IN AS
A PRIVATE CITIZEN HIS EXAM
INTO THIS BILL AND I HAVE TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE -- THE LOCAL
PREEMPTION THANK YOU FOR CALLING
IN ALL RIGHT THANK YOU BOB
JUST TO HAVE ROUGHLY
IN THE QUEUE TO THE QUEUE
OKAY GO AHEAD OKAY WE
HAVE LIKE NUMBER FIFTY THREE
THANK YOU TO DR KING'S --
IN OPPOSITION REPRESENTING
OUR EACH DAY RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION YOUR PARTNER
SO TO SHOW ORANGE COUNTY
AND THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION PACIFIC
SOUTHWEST AND FINALLY THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
CORRADINO LESSENING QUEUE LINE
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE WE WILL HAVE
HELLO MY NAME IS RYAN BELL
-- -- RESIDENTS HAVE TO BE
TO CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL COORDINATOR FOR TENANTS
TOGETHER AND STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE LOCAL PREEMPTION BECAUSE
REALLY RECKLESS ALREADY THANK
YOU MODDERS ANYONE ELSE ON
THE PHONE MY WISH AND TESTIFY
WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN THE
Q. FIVE ALL RIGHT I'LL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE ALSO
NOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORKS ON
DOING AUTHOR OF EIGHTY TWO
ONE SEVEN NINE IS PRESENT
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
SERVICE CENTER WIENER ABOUT
THAT OKAY IT WAS A LITTLE
HARDER TO FIT BETTER -- THANK
YOU NO QUESTIONS I THINK I
UNDERSTAND THE BILL -- WELL
BUT I DO WANNA EXPLAIN WHY WHY
I'M GOING TO BE VOTING AGAINST
THIS BILL TODAY AT FIRST I JUST
WANT TO SAY THIS IS NOTHING TO
DO WITH IT WITH THE AUTHORS THE
JOINT AUTHORS WHO ARE -- TWO
OF THE TWO HOUSING CHAMPIONS
THE LEGISLATURE AND -- TO MY
FAVORITE PEOPLE NOT THE SAME BUT
TO TO BROWN THOSE OR ANYTHING
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE WORK BUT OBVIOUSLY
THIS BILL IS NOT JUST ABOUT YOU
KNOW TO AUTHORS TO BRAINSTORM
SOME IS A BROADER -- EFFORTS
IN THE LEGISLATURE -- AND
-- IT PAINS ME TO VOTE AGAINST
THIS THIS BILL -- TODAY I'VE
I'VE SUPPORTED EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THE PREVIOUS -- EVICTION
PROTECTION -- BILLS -- EVEN
THOUGH NOT EVERY EVERYONE WAS
A LITTLE HAPPY AND I'M HAPPY
WITH THOSE BILLS BUT ULTIMATELY
THOSE BILLS PROTECTED A LOT OF
PEOPLE -- AND THIS BILL WILL
X. THERE'S GOOD IN IT -- THE
YOU KNOW THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE
IN THE QUEUE OF APPLIED IN AND
BECAUSE OF THE THIS BUREAUCRATIC
ISSUES A KNOCK ON PAID THEY WILL
BE PROTECTED BY THIS BILL --
AND THAT MAKES IT VERY TEMPTING
TO SUPPORT IT -- BUT THERE
IS ANOTHER SIDE TO IT -- FOR
ME -- WINDOWS EVEN THOUGH THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE WE'RE GETTING
A LOT BETTER IN TERMS OF THE
HEALTH OUTCOMES ALTHOUGH I'M
GIVEN VACCINATION RATES NOT
BEING WHERE THEY ARE WHO THE
HECK KNOWS WHERE WE'RE GONNA GO
AND THANK YOU MS WORKS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON ON THAT ISSUE --
-- BUT WE KNOW THAT THE ECONOMIC
FALLOUT FROM LAST TWO YEARS IS
NOT OVER AND THERE ARE STILL
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
HARMED THIS SIGNIFICANTLY
ECONOMIC ECONOMICALLY -- WHO
ARE STILL HURTING THEY HAVE
NOT RECOVERED ECONOMICALLY AND
THESE ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
LOW INCOME WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST
A BREADWINNER -- PEOPLE WHO
-- YOU KNOW HAVE HAVE RUN
EMPLOYED FOR A LARGER TIME AND
NO LONGER HAVE EVEN IF EVEN IF
THEY HAD A LITTLE NEST EGG MAY
NO LONGER HAVE THAT IT'S GOING
TO TAKE PEOPLE WHO LOST THEIR
BUSINESSES THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT RECOVERED
A LARGE NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS
-- AND HAVING THESE EVICTION
PROTECTIONS PROVIDES ABOUT
STABILITY YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
LOSE YOUR HOME I'M NOT PERFECT
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY A LONG TERM
SOLUTION BUT IT IS STABILITY TO
RECOVER NOW -- AND THAT'S WHY
I'VE ALWAYS SUPPORTED THEM EVEN
THOUGH I HAVEN'T AGREED WITH
EVERY SINGLE ASPECT OF EACH OF
THOSE -- HE'S OF THOSE BILLS
-- AND WHAT THE
WHAT REALLY PRESENTS A CHALLENGE
FOR ME WITH WITH THIS BILL
IS IT IT DOES AND THE VICTIM
PROTECTIONS FOR THE STATE OF
EXTRA PROTECTIONS FOR A LARGE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS READY
RETAINS THOSE PROTECTIONS ONLY
FOR THE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND I
THINKER ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY THERE ARE FOR THE HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
WHO WERE IN THE QUEUE WHO HAVE
APPLIED FOR RELIEF BUT HAVEN'T
RECEIVED IT THEY WILL RECEIVE
THREE MONTHS OF ADDITIONAL
PROTECTION SO THEY CAN HAVE A
HOPE OF GETTING THAT MONEY --
AND STAYING IN THEIR HOMES BUT
FOR EVERYONE ELSE PROTECTIONS GO
AWAY -- AND WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE YOU KNOW I THINK A TOTAL
OF THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE HAVE APPLIED TO MODE
TWO THIRDS OF THEM CAUGHT AND
RELEASED THE THIRD ABOUT A THIRD
OF THEM HAVE BEEN -- THAT'S A
LOT OF OTHER CALIFORNIANS AND
I'M CONFIDENT -- ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR RENT RELIEF AND HAVE NOT
APPLIED FOR WHATEVER REASON
THERE ARE A LOT OF REASONS THAT
PEOPLE DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT OR
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE OR
SINCE THEY HAVE NOT -- APPLIED
THEY WILL LOSE THEIR EVICTION
PROTECTIONS ON FRIDAY AND THEY
WILL BE FOREVER BARRED FROM
APPLYING FOR RENT RELIEF BECAUSE
THE CURTAIN COMES DOWN MIDNIGHT
ON THURSDAY NIGHT AND THEY CAN
NO LONGER APPLY FOR RENT
RELEASE -- AND THEY WILL NO
LONGER HAVE PROTECTIONS BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT APPLY AND IT'S NOT
FIXABLE THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO TO APPLY AND THEY CAN BE
-- EFFECTED PROMPTLY --
WE -- AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT
-- D. AND THIS IS THE BIGGEST
ISSUE FOR ME WITH THE PREEMPTION
-- THAT WE'RE ALSO SAYING OKAY
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA AND THE STATE
PROTECTIONS WE'RE NOT GOING TO
LET YOU APPLY TO TRY TO
STAY IN YOUR HOME OR TO TRIGGER
PROTECTIONS AND IF YOUR CITY
WANTS TO PROTECT YOU THEY CAN'T
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH WE'RE TAKING
AWAY THAT WAS ALWAYS THE DEAL
ON THIS AS AN ASIDE WE WERE
GONNA PUT STATE PROTECTIONS IN
PLACE AND IN EXCHANGE THE CITY'S
CANADA DR OWN PROTECTIONS RIGHT
AND THAT WAS A WE CAN HAVE
WHATEVER OPINION YOU WANT ABOUT
PREEMPTION IT WAS A REASONABLE
DEAL BUT THE STATE PROTECTIONS
ARE GOING AWAY AND NO MORE
LOCAL -- PROTECTIONS ARE
ALLOWED AT LEAST FOR THE
NEXT THREE MONTHS EXCEPT
IF YOU'RE IN ONE OF THE FAVORED
LUCKY CITIES CITY OF LA
I THINK OAKLAND ALAMEDA
URAL OUT FUSE IF YOU'RE LUCKY
TO LIVE IN THOSE CITIES YOU GET
TO KEEP YOUR LOCAL PROTECTIONS
THEY GOT TO KICK AGAIN BUT
NOT IN SAN FRANCISCO OR
-- L. A. COUNTY OR ANYWHERE ELSE
THAT IS A PART OF THAT FAVORITE
LIST AND WHAT'S THE DISTINCTION
OF WHO GETS TO BE ON THAT LIST
OR NOT IF YOU ENACTED BEFORE
AUGUST NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
THAT THEN YOU'RE ALLOWED TO KEEP
YOUR LOCAL PROTECTIONS BECAUSE
YOU -- ADOPTED BEFORE AUGUST
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
AND DIDN'T LET IT EXPIRE AND WE
AUTHORIZES AFTER THAT IF YOU
DIDN'T ADOPTED BY THEN -- FOR
EXPIRES AND GOT GOT RE
AUTHORIZED THEN YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO SO SAN FRANCISCO IS
NOT BY RESIDENTS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO HAVE CODED EVICTION
PROTECTIONS ANYMORE VIEW OF
THE CITY OF LA YOU CAN --
DIED IS -- THERE'S NO RATIONAL
BASIS FOR THAT DISTINCTION
ABOUT WHAT CITIES ARE ALLOWED
TO HAVE A LOCAL PROTECTIONS AND
WHAT ARE AND IT'S AN ARBITRARY
DISTINCTION -- AND SO I'M SAYING
ALL THESE THINGS NOT TO DUMP
OVER THE BY NOW THIS BILL I'M
PRETTY CONFIDENT IT'S GOING TO
PASS AND AND LEASE TO TENANTS IN
THE QUEUE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES AND I
SUPPORT THAT THOUSAND PERCENT
AND IT PAINS ME NOT TO BE ABLE
TO VOTE FOR THE BILL BECAUSE I
WANT TO HELP AND PROTECT THOSE
PEOPLE BUT I NEED TO EXPLAIN TO
THOSE PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE WHY
I'M NOT VOTING FOR THIS BILL
I NEED TO EXPLAIN TO MY OWN
CONSTITUENTS ARE WHY I CAN'T
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
TODAY SO AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
YOU JOINT AUTHORS FOR FOR
DOING DOES AN EXCELLENT PART
OF THIS BILL YOU'RE PROTECTING
A LOT OF PEOPLE BY MOVING THIS
LEGISLATION FORWARD AND I THANK
YOU -- FOR THAT AS WELL AS OUR
OTHER WORK ON HOUSING BUT I
WANT TO EXPLAIN WHY WHY I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU SAID EARLIER
CENTER MORICHES
JUST TO MAYBE FOR POINT OF
CLARIFICATION -- WHEN THIS
ISSUE FIRST CAME UP MANY MOONS
BACK -- I SUPPORTED EXPECTING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
DEGREE RESOLUTION -- AND THEN
IT CAME BACK A DIFFERENT FORM
AGAIN AND I WILL DISAPPOINTED
THIS IS ALMOST IT SEEMS LIKE
THIS IS A GET OUT OF JAIL FREE
CARD FOR CALIFORNIA TO REMEDY
SOME OF THE BUREAUCRATIC AND
ADMINISTRATIVE HICCUPS ALONG THE
WAY -- THIS TO ME
SEEMS RELATIVELY BENIGN
ONLY BECAUSE IT'S FOR SUCH SHORT
DURATION SO MAYBE YOU CAN HELP
EXPLAIN WHAT IS THE IMPACT
OF THIS SHORT DURATION AND WHY
IS A CONSEQUENTIAL IN IMPORTANT
YEAH THANK YOU FOR THROUGHOUT
EUROPE SURE DO THE TRICK
WOULD EVER YOU LIKE TO RESPOND
OKAY THANK YOU AND -- I AM
GLAD TO BE HERE WITH JOINT
AUTHORS SOME REMEMBER WICKS
WHO MAY WANT TO ALSO RESPOND TO
THAT I IT SPECIFICALLY IF I MAY
-- THIS WAS A VERY CAREFULLY
-- NEGOTIATED AGREEMENT
TO BE ABLE TO BALANCE BOTH THE
RENTER AND THE LANDLORD TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL PARTIES FOLKS
GET TO STAY IN THEIR HOME OR
THEIR LIVING SPACE AND ALSO THE
ONE THAT IS THE LANDLORD THE
OWNER OF THE PROPERTY IS ALSO
MADE WHOLE AT THE SAME TIME
SPECIFIC TO SAN FRANCISCO AND
THANK YOU TO MY -- TO MY SENATOR
CALLING THAT HAS MADE SOME VERY
VALID POINTS AND AND PASSIONATE
ABOUT WANTING TO SUPPORT AND
DO SO ON BOTH SIDES THE STATE'S
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WAS ALREADY
SET TO CLOSE ON MARCH THE
THIRTY FIRST WHICH MEANS THAT
ALL THE VIXENS WERE GOING
TO EXPIRE FOR PEOPLE OF THAT
FICTION PROTECTIONS WE'RE GOING
TO EXPIRE FOR PEOPLE WHO OWED
BACK RENT FROM OCTOBER UNTIL
NOW WITHOUT AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE
AWAITING THE PAYMENTS THAT ARE
IMMINENT COULD BE HE VISITED
ON APRIL THE FIRST INCLUDING
PEOPLE IN SAN FRANCISCO BECAUSE
SAN FRANCISCO'S NEW ORDINANCE
ONLY PROTECTS PEOPLE FOR NON
PAYMENT OF RENT MOVING FORWARD
NOT FOR BACK RENT A BOAT SO
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL
-- -- IS OWED BACK RENT
FROM THE STATE HI AND
IT HAPPENS ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH -- AND ALL THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION -- I THINK
THE CHALLENGES WITH PEOPLE WHO
HAVE APPLIED MONTHS AGO HAVEN'T
RECEIVED THOSE FUNDS AND IT IS
OUR HOPE THAT THERE THAT THOSE
FUNDS WILL BE RECEIVED AT THAT
POINT OKAY AND THAT IS WHAT IS
CRITICAL AND IT'S YOU KNOW I
THINK FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT IS
NOT THE LANDLORD AND THE TENANT
FAULT THAT THE STATE HASN'T
FUNDED AND NOT ENOUGH TIME
RIGHT AND SO WE'RE BUYING MORE
TIME SO THAT THE PROGRAM CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED SUCCESSFULLY SO IS
THERE AN EXPECTATION THAT THE
STATE WILL SATISFY ALL THESE
OUTSTANDING ACCOUNTS BY JUNE
-- BECAUSE AFTER THAT WE ARE NOW
OFFICIALLY DONE THAT IS THE GOAL
DO YOU ANTICIPATE THAT IF IT'S
NOT ACHIEVE THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
COMING BACK ASKING FOR ANOTHER
EXTENSION WELL I I BELIEVE THE
THE THE FACTOR HERE IS THAT IS
THAT THE MONEY THAT WERE CUT
THAT WAS COMING FROM THE FEDS
THE FUNDING COMING FROM THE FEDS
VERY SLOW IN ROLLING OUT TO
THE STATE WHICH IS WHY THE
STATE'S STALLED THE APPROVAL
PROCESS NOW THAT THE FUNDING IS
PRESENT AND WE'RE READY TO GO
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD OF FULL
WITH THE PROCESS AS FAR AS THE
APPROVAL AND AND GETTING THE
CHECKS OUT IN SO I'M WILLING I'M
WILLING TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY
-- AND I'VE HAD MY OWN PERSONAL
GRIEVANCES ON THE BALANCING ACT
OF LOOKING AFTER TENANTS FOR
AS WELL AS LANDLORDS BECAUSE
BOTH WERE AFFECTED AND EACH HAD
AN OBLIGATION TO TO ONE OR BOTH
OR THIRD PARTIES -- THE FACT
THAT THIS IS GOING TO EXPIRE IN
JUNE I'M WILLING TO TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS TODAY BUT
IF CALIFORNIA CAN'T GET -- IT'S
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES CORRECT
I WOULD HOPE THAT THAT YOU'RE
DONE AS WELL THAT WERE ALL
DONE AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
MOVE FOR ANOTHER EXTENSION
-- BUT OF COURSE YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S WOULD CALIFORNIA'S
-- IT'S A BEHEMOTH AND A LOT
OF INSTRUMENTS I PLAY BUT I'LL
BE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS TODAY
-- IN HOPES OF -- OF RESOLVING
THIS ISSUE ONCE AND FOR ALL
THANK YOU SIR BORDERS ANYONE
ELSE SITTING OF THE HOUSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
I TO WANT TO THINK THAT THE
AUTHORS BECAUSE I KNOW -- THIS
IS NOT AN EASY FEAT FOR ANY
OF US AND IF WE'RE GOING TO I
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BUT -- IF WE'RE GONNA
SUPPORT ANYONE YOU KNOW IT'S
THE THESE FOLKS IN THE QUEUE
OF COURSE BUT OF COURSE THERE
IS A LARGE SEGMENT OF FOLKS
THAT COULDN'T GET ENOUGH AFTER
YEAR FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND
TECHNICAL GLITCHES MANY OF
OF WHOM OF FOLKS THAT DID NOT
SPEAK ENGLISH SPANISH SPEAKERS
CHINESE SPEAKERS WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO GET IN THE QUEUE AND FOR ME
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES ABOUT
A VERY SMALL PORTION OF CITY OF
LA SO THERE ARE PROTECTIONS
FOR THOSE FOLKS IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES FOR THREE MONTHS
AND THEN YOU GO ACROSS THE
STREET TO UNINCORPORATED SOUTH
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES AND THEY
ARE NOT PROTECTED NET THAT
IS ONE OF THE MOST UNSERVED
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
ALL OF LOS ANGELES SO LIKE MY
MY COLLEAGUE IN SAN FRANCISCO I
I'M I'M PAINED BY THIS BECAUSE
WE WE KNOW WE CAN DO MORE BUT I
I JUST THINK YOU BECAUSE WE'RE
DOING SOMETHING AND I'D RATHER
DO SOMETHING THAN NOT TO DO
ANYTHING -- AND I KNOW L. A.
COUNTY HAS HAD A A REMEDY AND
THEY'VE ACTUALLY HAD A REALLY
DEEP YOU KNOW THOUGHTFUL PROCESS
ON THIS IT'S JUST I WISH I WISH
THERE WAS SOMETHING MORE THAT WE
CAN DO AND I I ALTHOUGH I HAVE
DEEP CONCERNS I WILL SUPPORT
THIS BUT I ALSO WANT TO KNOW
THAT -- AND I WANT TO BE ABLE
TO MESSAGE TO MY CONSTITUENTS
-- VERY CLEARLY AND WHAT THIS
WILL DO BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
THEM TO THINK THAT THEY HAVE
-- PROTECTIONS THAT THEY MAY
NOT AND SO WITH THAT I WILL
SUPPORT TODAY BUT OF COURSE
THEY WANT US TO CONTINUE TO THE
DISCUSSIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU OTHER QUESTIONS CONSISTENT
-- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT
TO ECHO THE THE COMMENTS OF MY
MY COLLEAGUES -- AND
THE RELUCTANCE THAT I I I DON'T
WANT TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
WITH MY CONSTITUENTS YET
AND I THINK WITH THIS VOTE
I DON'T KNOW THE WE OBLIGATE
OURSELVES TO THIS BEING
-- THE END OF THE
THE ASSISTANCE EFFORT I THINK
THIS OBLIGATES US TO LOOK
TO THE BUDGET TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR SOME ACTION
AND I RECOGNIZE WHERE TO
STOP GAP SITUATION AND THAT
DEALS HAVE TO BE NEGOTIATED BUT
I'M I'M I'M CASTING A VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE TODAY
WITH THE RELEASE OF PERSONAL
COMMITMENT ON THAT FRONT I WOULD
HOPE IS A BODY WE WE ACCEPT THAT
MANSELL OURSELVES AND NOT TO
NOT BE DONE SO THANK YOU SISTER
AND OTHERS SENATE ALSO THANK
YOU I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS -- FOR WORKING SO HARD
-- I WILL BE VOTING FOR
THE MEASURE BUT I WANT TO
SHARE SOME THOUGHTS -- ONE
IS AS SEVERAL HAVE SAID
VOTING FOR THIS BILL PROTECTS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS -- FROM EVICTION
AND -- THEY'RE WAITING TO GET
THE ASSISTANCE THE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AND WE OWE IT TO THEM
THEY DID EVERYTHING THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO -- I KNOW
IN ADDITION TO THOSE WHO HAVE
NOT YET GOTTEN THE AID BUT WHO
APPLIED IN ADDITION TO THEM
THERE WERE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
WHO WE HAD ALREADY ASSISTED
-- SO THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
ME I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
-- ALL OF THE ORGANIZATIONS
WHO WORKED REALLY REALLY HARD
FOR THE OUTREACH ON SATURDAY
AND IN MY AREA AND CENTRAL
LOS ANGELES WE HAD ANOTHER
HOUSING FAIR IN WHICH A HUNDRED
SEEMS LIKE SMALL BUT A HUNDRED
PEOPLE WERE ASSISTED THE
-- MANY REASONS IN WHICH THEY
HAD NOT DONE IT BEFORE ONE IS
-- THERE WERE YOU KNOW THERE
WERE SOME SENIORS WHO ARE
UNSURE HOW TO DO IT -- TO THE
INTERNET -- THERE ARE THOSE
WHO DISTRUST GOVERNMENT NOT
SURE WHAT IT MEANT DO THEY
HAVE TO PAY IT BACK THEY'RE ALL
SORTS OF OF REASONS FOR THAT --
BUT I KNOW THAT -- THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN --
HAVE BEEN ASSISTANT I THINK
WE NEED TO KEEP ON WORKING
TO PROTECT ANYBODY NOBODY
SHOULD HAVE TO FACE EVICTION
AND SO I THINK IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO NOT JUST
SAY WELL THAT'S THE END ON
MARCH THIRTY FIRST THAT'S
THE END OF IT ALL BUT
RATHER AND LET ANY --
LANDLORD THAT USES THIS AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO EVICT
-- YOU KNOW REALLY NEEDS TO
KNOW THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
LEGAL ASSISTANCE AND THEY WILL
BE ATTORNEYS DEFENDING THOSE
TENANTS IF IT'S DONE IN
UNFAIR AND ILLEGAL WAY
WE WE PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE
FACING EVICTIONS -- AND I THINK
THAT WAS THE WHOLE THING SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT -- THERE IS
WILL THERE IS STILL ASSISTANCE
OFFERED LEGAL AID -- WE GOT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT INFORMATION
GETS OUT AGAIN I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ANY LANDLORD WHO
IS A TRIES TO ABUSE ANY
VICT -- REALLY KNOWS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ATTORNEYS
DEFENDING THOSE TENANTS OF THE
MOMENT THAT THAT THEY NEED IT
-- AND THEN FINALLY WE'VE
GOT SEVENTY TWO HOURS
-- AND I THINK THAT --
WHETHER IT'S A HUNDRED OR
WHETHER IT'S THE THOUSANDS OF
THAT MANY MORE PEOPLE SHOULD BE
-- SHOULD BE -- HEALTH --
I WOULD LIKE TO FEEL A WHOLE
LOT MORE COMFORTABLE --
IN NEGOTIATIONS YOU DON'T
GET EVERYTHING BUT WE FOUGHT
LIKE HELL AND I THINK WE
CONTINUE TO FIGHT LIKE HELL
FOR THOSE TENANTS MOVE THE
BILL THANK THANK YOU THE
SERVICE OF THE THREE DIGIT CODE
YES YES THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT SIR WHAT HOUSEKI
CENTER COAST MOVES WILL
OTHERS WISHING COMMON NO
ALL RIGHT WHAT ONE FINAL COMMENT
THE RESPONSE OF THE WHAT'S
CENTER WIENER SAID I THINK
ABOUT HEARD YOU CORRECTLY SO
THE JOIN US IS YOUR FAVORITE
LEGISLATORS WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
THE SENATE JUST A NOTE THAT
THAT THAT THEIR MOM LONG AMONG
MY FAVORITES ALL I MIGHT FEEL
BETTER MYSELF I SAW THIS THING
HAD BEEN IMPACTED BUT YOU
MIGHT A LITTLE BETTER AMONG MY
FAVORITE LONGER FAIR ALL RIGHT
ALL RIGHT THIS BEEN IN MOTION
MADAM I WAS GOING TO GIVE THE
AUTHORS AN UPTURN OLD CLOTHES
WHICH WHAT CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND SENATOR
WINNERS AMONG -- ONE OF MY APPS
OF ALL TIME -- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR VERY THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS
AND OBSERVATIONS OBVIOUSLY
-- THIS IS BEEN A VERY TOUGH
ROAD TO PAVE AND MOVE FORWARD
AND IT'S FOOT -- MANY MANY
FOLKS IN A IN A VERY DIFFICULT
POSITION BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE MUST DO AS WAS ALREADY
STATED DOING SOMETHING IS BETTER
THAN DOING NOTHING AND IT'S
THROUGH THE CHAIR FOR -- MY
JOIN AUTOMATE CLOSE AS WELL --
THANK YOU I'VE NINE FAVORITES
HERE ON THE COMMITTEE TODAY
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US --
I JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE SOME
OF THE FRUSTRATION HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED BY SO MY COLLEAGUES
I HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR AND
-- YOU KNOW SENATOR GONZALEZ
YOU ARE CORRECT I THINK THE
THE PROGRAM THE LIMITATIONS
OF LANGUAGE HAS BEEN HAVE BEEN
REAL AND THAT IS FOR SO IMPACTS
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES YOU
KNOW I THINK SENATOR WIENER YOU
RAISE SOME EXCELLENT POINTS AS
WELL AROUND THE PENSION PIECE
THAT I'VE HEARD AS WELL AND I
SHARE THOSE THINGS AND I ALSO
BELIEVE -- YOU KNOW WE COULD
HAVE DONE A BETTER JOB THE
ADMINISTRATION COULD HAVE DONE
A BETTER JOB WE HAVE TO ASK SOME
TOUGH QUESTIONS NOW IN TERMS OF
HOW ARE WE EFFECTIVELY SERVING
OUR CONSTITUENTS AS GOVERNMENT
YOU KNOW I'M A DEMOCRATICALLY
GOVERNMENT CAN HELP PEOPLE WELL
THEN WE NEED TO DO OUR JOB AND
DO DOING THAT AND HELP THE MOST
PEOPLE WE POSSIBLY CAN AND I
THINK WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT HELPS THOSE COUPLE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE
QUEUE YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO HONOR
THAT COMMITMENT THOSE FOLKS HAVE
HAVE PUT FORTH THEIR APPLICATION
THEY ARE WAITING ON THESE
FUNDS THOSE FUNDS ARE CRITICAL
WE NEED TO DO THAT BUT I ALSO
THINK THIS TO SENATOR STERN'S --
COMMENTS THIS SHOULD BE A CALL
TO ACTION TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THESE FOLKS ARE SOME OF THE MOST
UNDERSERVED PEOPLE IN OUR STATE
AND WE HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION
TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEADS AND I'VE USED
YOU HOUSING SECURITY AS AS A
MORAL ISSUE WHEN WE SEE THE
HOMELESSNESS WE HAVE TO COMBAT
THAT SO WITHOUT THIS BILL I DO
WORRY WE WILL SEE A MASS WAVE
OF EVICTIONS THAT IS WHAT IS
ON THE LINE HERE AND I WELCOME
AND SENATORS ARE ALSO IN THE
FIGHT FIGHT LIKE HELL ATTITUDE
AND LET US ALL THINK ABOUT HOW
WE CONTINUE HOUSING POLICY WE
CONTINUE HOUSING PRODUCTION
WE CONTINUE TO HELP OUR TENANT
TENETS BECAUSE WHAT KOBE DID
IS IT SHINED A SPOTLIGHT ON
SOMETHING IS ALREADY HAPPENING
THE INCOME INEQUALITY IT WAS
THAT WAS ALREADY HAPPENING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO THE
CONVERSATION AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU --
MENTERI COUNCIL RECALL THE ROLE
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY NINE BY FAMILY
MEMBERS WICKS AND GRAYSON WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR AYE CASKEY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS -- BURKE
-- BURGER AYE PORGES GORGEOUS
I DID US SO I DID US SO I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
JONES JONES I IT LAYERED
LAYERED I MCGUIRE STERN
STERN I WHITE HOUSE WHITE
HOUSE HE AYE WIENER NO
WINNER NO -- SO FAR YOU HAVE
EIGHT TO ONE WITH SOME
MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT --
HE'S STILL ON ALL THANK YOU
-- I BELIEVE TEMPORARILY SO
IN A THERE'S BEEN
A COUP AND NUMBER HAS BEEN
REMOVED RELIEVED OF DUTY
DO YOU HAVE THE -- OUR MOTION
A CONSENSUS THIRTY
TWO PERCENT YEAH YEAH WE
OKAY ALL RIGHTS --
WE ARE MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ITEM SENATE RESOLUTION
FORTY FIVE SENATOR
MEN -- WELCOME
THANK YOU CHAIR BOARD JUST
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
SUCCESSFUL CO FOR
THE LAST FORTUNATELY WE'RE
NOT SEEING COMMUNITIES BE
SUCCESSFUL THESE DAYS BUT --
I WANT TO THANK -- CHAIR ON
BURKE FOR LEAVING RIGHT BEFORE
MY PRESENTATION AND THANK YOU
THE COMMITTEE STAFF HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE ON THIS
RESOLUTION SENATE RESOLUTION
FORTY FIVE RECOGNIZES THAT
ACADEMIC FREEDOM FOR COLLEGE
AND UNIVERSITY PROFESSORS IS
CRITICAL FOR FOSTERING HEALTHY
DISCOURSE IN THE CLASSROOM MY
PARENTS CAME TO THIS COUNTRY
LIKE SO MANY OTHERS IN SEARCH
OF BETTER LIFE MY PARENTS CAME
AS GRADUATE STUDENTS -- AND
THEY CHOSE AMERICA FOR THE
SAME REASON A LOT OF -- HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENTS COME TO
THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE OF OUR
EXCEPTIONAL HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS I THINK IT'S SAFE
TO SAY AMERICAN HIGHER IT IS
THE ENVY OF THE WORLD NOT JUST
TODAY BUT THROUGHOUT ALL TIME
AND I THINK IT'S ALSO SAFE TO
SAY THAT OUR ACADEMIC FREEDOM
AND INDEPENDENCE ARE THE BEDROCK
OF OUR ACADEMIC EXCEPTIONALISM
IN THIS COUNTRY -- THE PURPOSE
OF HIGHER EDUCATION AS WE KNOW
IS TO GROW INTELLECTUALLY IN
ORDER TO PROMOTE THIS ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS MUST PROVIDE
A SETTING THAT ENCOURAGES
CHALLENGING ONE'S ASSUMPTIONS
AND BELIEFS ABOUT THE WORLD AS
A FORMER PROFESSOR MYSELF AT
UC IRVINE HI I AM WONDERING THE
SAME THING ON HERE YEAH YOU
GUYS ARE -- AT THE WRONG
HEARING I THINK THAT THANK
YOU MODERATOR WE MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THAT LINE IS CLOSED
AS A FORMER EDUCATOR MYSELF I
KNOW THE ROLE OF AN EDUCATOR IS
TO FACILITATE A FULL AN ROBUST
DISCUSSIONS WHICH REQUIRES AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE SOMETIMES
THEY'RE UNCOMFORTABLE THINGS
DISCUSSED WHERE SOMETIMES THERE
IS AN OPEN BUT RESPECTFUL DEBATE
BETWEEN OPPOSING VIEWPOINTS
AND THAT HAS TO START WITH
EDUCATORS THEMSELVES ACADEMIC
FREEDOM AS THE SUN AS DEFINED
BY THIS RESOLUTION WOULD MEAN
THE FREEDOM OF FACULTY TO TEACH
CONDUCT RESEARCH AND SPEAK AS
CITIZENS WITHOUT INTERFERENCE
ARE RESTRAINED BY INSTITUTIONS
SUCH AS THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
TOP POLITICAL FIGURES ARE ON THE
OTHER ENTITIES -- WE CANNOT BE
-- IMPOSING POLITICS ON TO
ACADEMIC FREEDOM WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY AND -- ARE DOLLARS
DAVIS IN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ECONOMIC SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WENDY
BRILL WYNKOOP THE PRESIDENT
OF THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THANK YOU CENTER -- AS HE
MENTIONED -- YOUR FIRST
WITNESS IS DELORES DAVISON
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
TO LAWRENCE ON THE LINE
YEAH FOR MY MAIL ONLINE IF
YOU CAN KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
TWO MINUTES WITH THAT WOULD
BE APPRECIATED PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON CHECK ORDERS
AND -- MEMBERS OF THE MONEY
BEFORE SAY THE FUNDS AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES REPRESENTING THE FIFTY
EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE FACTORED
IN THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM I AM ALSO A
FULL TIME AND TENURED FACULTY
IN THE DEPARTMENTS OF HISTORY
AND WOMEN'S STUDIES AT HILL
COLLEGE YESTERDAY HE HAS LONG
RECOGNIZED THE IMPORTANCE
OF ACADEMIC FREEDOM IT'S
FUNDAMENTAL TO ENSURING THAT
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
FUNCTION PUBLIC FOOD BECAUSE
IT CREATES THE CONDITIONS FOR
THE UNFETTERED ADVANCEMENT OF
KNOWLEDGE IN THE FIRST TWO TO
THREE ON THE BACK OF THEM
FREEDOM SHOULD NOT BE CONFUSED
WITH THE PROVISION FOR FREE
SPEECH GUARANTEED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT FREEDOM OF SPEECH
PROTECTS FROM INFRINGEMENT
OF SPEECH BY THE GOVERNMENT
ACADEMIC FREEDOM IS THE FREEDOM
OF TEACHING FACULTY TO TEACH
CONDUCT RESEARCH ON THE EFFECTS
OF THE OUT INTERFERENCE OR
RESTRAINT BY THEIR INSTITUTIONS
FOR TRUCKS YOU FOR THE CALL
FIGURES OR OTHER ENTITIES
ACTUALLY MORE RESTRICTIVE THAN
THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND THIS
IS NOT THE FACT THAT YOU KNOW I
SUPPOSE THE PERSONAL POLITICAL
VIEWS ON STUDENTS NOR COLLEGE
OR UNIVERSITY REGULATIONS
SAID ANY FORM OF PROFESSIONAL
INCOMPETENCE OR EACH UP OTHER
SUBJECT MATTER OR THE OFFICIAL
COURSE SOMEONE OF RECORD IN
RECENT YEARS MANY FACULTY AND
FACULTY ORGANIZATIONS THAT FOCUS
ON RESEARCHING HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES WELL
THERE ARE GOOD NOR BY MUCH
OF ACADEMIA THIS IS LEADING
TO A GRADUAL DECOMPOSITION
OF THE CURRICULUM WHICH IS
OFTEN BASED ON PATRIARCHAL
YOUR APPEAL EUROCENTRIC IDEAS
I DON'T THINK TO WIN BATTLES
AGAINST THE TEACHING OF
CRITICAL RACE THEORY OF ANTI
RACISM UNEVENNESS OF THE WORK
DAY IN THE CLASSROOM REPAIRS
FOR CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO
DISTINGUISH ITSELF PROVIDE
PROTECTING THE CLASSROOM OF THE
STATE FOR THE ROBUST EXCHANGE
IDEAS AND IT'S FOR THESE
REASONS OF THE ANTHROPOCENE
SUPPORT AS ARE FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
A MOVIE ON TO US THAT OUR MEN
SECOND -- ATTENDEE THERE
BE WINDY BRILL -- WYNKOOP
IS SHE ON THE LINE
GOOD AFTERNOON YEAH YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD GREAT
WONDERFUL GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WHEN HE FOR A WINE COOPER I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES PROUD MONSTER
OF SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY FIVE
I'M ALSO A FACULTY MEMBER AT
COLLEGE OF THE CANYONS THE IDEA
OF ACADEMIC FREEDOM IS NEITHER
NEW NOR LIMITED TO THE UNITED
STATES AMERICAN ASSOCIATION
OF UNIVERSITY PROFESSIONALS
NINETEEN FORTY STATEMENT OF
PRINCIPLES ON ACADEMIC FREEDOM
AND TENURE BECOME THE STANDARD
AND DEFINED ACADEMIC FREEDOM
AND THE FREEDOM FOR FACULTY TO
CONDUCT RESEARCH THE FREEDOM
TO DISCUSS THEIR SUBJECT IN
THE CLASSROOM AND THE FREEDOM
FROM INSTITUTIONAL CENSORSHIP
WHEN THEY THINK IT'S THE BEST
ACADEMIC ACADEMIC FREEDOM
ENABLED FACULTY TO DECOLONIZE
THE CURRICULUM AND MANY HAVE
MADE EFFORTS TO DO SO HOWEVER
THOSE SAME FACULTY MEMBERS
FOUND THEMSELVES A PATH AND
OFF ON SOCIAL MEDIA BY THOSE
WHO DISAGREE WITH THEM I'M HERE
PART TIME FACULTY WITHOUT DUE
PROCESS ARE THE MOST AT RISK
OF THE THE TASK AT COLLEGE
OF THE CANYONS THE FACULTY
MEMBER HAD HER SYLLABUS WHICH
ENCOURAGES STUDENTS TO TAKE A
WHITE PRIVILEGE QUIZ POSTED TO
THE REDSTATE WEBSITE ALONG WITH
HER PERSONAL CONTACT INFORMATION
SHE WAS HARASSED FOR WEEKS AND
EVEN RECEIVED PHYSICAL THREATS
THIS IS NOT UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA
FACULTY REPORTED TODAY A U.
P. OVER FIFTY INSTANCES OF
HARASSMENT THROUGH SOCIAL
MEDIA IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
ALONE AND FORTY PERCENT OF
THOSE REPORTS CONCERNED GREAT
WRAPPING A FACULTY MEMBER FOR
ENCOURAGING STUDENTS TO THINK
CRITICALLY AND QUESTION THE
STATUS QUO CAN HAVE A CHILLING
EFFECT ON BETHAN EFFORTS
TO ADVANCE KNOWLEDGE IN THE
PURSUIT OF TRUTH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU ARE MOVING INTO
-- ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED -- ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THIS ROOM
-- THAT WISHING TO -- BE IN
SUPPORT OF S. R. FORTY FIVE
SEEING NONE MODERATE DO WE HAVE
ANY -- OF FOLKS ON THE LINE
AND IF SO IF YOU COULD TELL ME
HOW MANY MIGHT BE IN THE QUEUE
IF YOU'RE PART OF AB
R. FORTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
IN THAT THE ONE AND
THEN ZERO BURNED PART
OF F. R. FORTY FIVE
MEDICARE WE HAVE NO SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU AND HAVE
YOU HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM OPPOSITION
APPARENTLY THERE'S NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION -- WITNESSED THIS
BILL ANY -- INDIVIDUALS IN
THIS ROOM ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE MODERATE LET'S
MOVE TO THE LINES DO WE HAVE
ANY INDIVIDUALS IN THE QUEUE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO -- S. R. FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OF
AB R. FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO IN THAT
ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
YOUR MEMBERS ARE MY APOLOGIES
FF ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT THAT
CALIFORNIA ECOLOGY DEPENDENCE
-- MY NAME IS DAVID HAWKINS
-- WE REPRESENT -- TOLD
SOUTH BETWEEN COLLEGE FACULTY
TEACHING HAPPENING STUDENTS
ARE VERY MUCH IN CONTROL
OR FORTY FIVE THANK YOU --
MODERATELY REMIND FOLKS WE ARE
IN THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION
-- WITNESSES FOR --
GIVEN OPPOSITION UP AT OUR
FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO IN THAT ONE
AND THEN THERE UP IN OPPOSITION
HERE WE HAVE NOT POSITION IF
YOU AT THE TIME K. -- HAVING
GONE OUT TO THE PUBLIC BRING IT
BACK TO YOU WITH THE DAIS -- ANY
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE WISHING
TO COMMENT PROPOSED QUESTIONS
THE NILE THE JUMP IN FIVE
CENTERMAN I'D AS A
AS SOMEONE WITH A BACKGROUND
IN ACADEMIA I APPRECIATE
-- ACADEME ACADEMIC FREEDOM
AND I'VE CERTAINLY VALUE IT I
THINK WHEN WE HAVE A DYNAMIC
ENVIRONMENT -- IT IS SUCH AS
WE TRY TO FOSTER IN LAW SCHOOL
AND FRANKLY ANY -- ACADEMIC
ENVIRONMENT IT HELPS WHEN
STUDENTS ARE CHALLENGED IN
YOU HAVE PROFESSORS -- WILLING
TO PUT FORWARD IDEAS NOT
NECESSARILY -- -- OF THEIR OWN
LIKING BUT ONE DESIGNED TO YOU
KNOW GENERATE CONVERSATION TO
TO QUESTION AND PUSH AND PROD
DODD TO DEVELOP THESE CRITICAL
THINKING SKILLS ANALYTICAL
THINKING PROCESS IS I THINK ONE
OF THE GREAT THINGS ABOUT THE
AMERICAN EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
AS OPPOSED TO OTHER PLACES WHERE
IT TENDS TO BE MORE LECTURE
STYLE OR IS MORE ENGAGING
-- I GUESS I'M TRYING TO
CORRECT MY MY ARMS AROUND THE
NECESSITY FOR THIS BECAUSE SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT I HEARD
FROM FOLKS -- THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT -- A SYLLABUS PUTTING
PROUD BEING PUT OUT IN THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN AND THEN SOMEBODY
YOU KNOW BEING CASTIGATED AND IN
SOCIAL MEDIA HOW WOULD
THAT PERTAIN TO ACADEMIC FREEDOM
BECAUSE IS THAT NOT INTIMIDATION
BY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AS
OPPOSED TO THE ACADEMIC SETTING
YEAH WHICH ISN'T TOTALLY
DIFFERENT VENUES THE POLICE
HAVE BEEN -- SERVER SO I I AGREE
WITH YOUR ELOQUENT REMARKS ON
THE IMPORTANCE ECONOMIC FREEDOM
HAVING TIÃU WE ARE BOTH FORMER
PROFESSORS -- AND WE KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE AS HE SAID OF OF
GETTING PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR
COMFORT SOME OF THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION THAT THAT MIGHT
MAKE PEOPLE FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE
OF MY CHALLENGE SOME OF THEIR
EXISTING WORLDVIEWS OF THAT IS
AT THE HEART OF AMERICAN HIGHER
EDUCATION IT'S YOU KNOW AT THE
HEART OF CRITICAL THINKING --
AND I DO THINK THIS RESOLUTION
IS NECESSARY TO AFFIRM
THE STATE'S BELIEVING THAT
BELIEF IN ECONOMIC FREEDOM --
UNFORTUNATELY SEEING A RISE IN
ATTACKS ON PROFESSORS ON TENURE
PROFESSORS IN PARTICULAR IS
ONE OF MY WITNESSES POINTED
OUT I THAT IS OFTEN LEADS TO
DISCIPLINE OR CONSEQUENCES
FROM THE GOVERNING BOARDS OR --
ACADEMIC -- -- THE
THE THE SORT OF A THE FOLKS IN
CHARGE OF THESE INSTITUTIONS --
IN RESPONSE TO THE POLITICS WE
SEEN IT AROUND THE STATE WE'VE
SEEN AROUND THE COUNTRY -- AND
UNFORTUNATE THING -- ON BOTH
THE LEFT AND THE RIGHT YOU'RE
STARTING TO SEE A CONCERTED
EFFORT TO TRY TO IDENTIFY AND
TAKE OUT OF CONTEXT REMARKS THAT
MIGHT BE VIEWED AS OFFENSIVE
TO DIFFERENT TYPES OF GROUPS
AND THERE'S COUNTLESS EXAMPLES
OF THESE I THINK MY WITNESSES
HAVE MADE IT MAY HAVE SOME OF
THESE AND READY AT HAND BUT --
YOU KNOW AT A TIME WHEN WE DO
SEE A RISE WITH LIBERTARIANS
A RISE OF ATTEMPTS TO TRY TO
LIMIT FREE SPEECH AND DISSENT
-- AND THE POLITICIZATION OF
SPEECHES I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US AS A BODY HERE TO
REAFFIRM VERY LOUDLY AND CLEARLY
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S NOT
JUST FREE SPEECH BUT ACADEMIC
FREEDOM AND THE ABILITY AND
FREEDOM AND INDEPENDENCE OF OUR
EDUCATORS IN HIGHER ED TO BE
ABLE TO SEE -- YOU KNOW THINK
FREELY TO PROMOTE A HEALTHY
DIALOGUE IN THEIR CLASSROOMS TO
RESEARCH WHAT THEY LIKE TO DO
WITHOUT FEAR OF REPERCUSSIONS
BECAUSE THEIR VIEWS ARE THE
DISCUSSION THEY'RE PROMOTING
MIGHT MIGHT OFFEND SOMEBODY THAT
I THINK THAT'S REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT
I'LL I'LL I'LL DRAW THIS TO TO A
CLOSE ONE OF THE ALL OF THE
FOLKS WHO COMMENTED TALKED
ABOUT DECOLONIZING ACADEMIA
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WAS BORN
YESTERDAY THINKING THAT AND
I'LL THROW OUT SOME SOME SOME
NAMES OF UNIVERSITIES JUST BY
WAY OF EXAMPLE THAT YOU KNOW
IF YOU HAD A -- A CENTER LEFT
PROFESSOR GOING TO HILLSDALE
COLLEGE TO TEACH -- OR IF
YOU HAD BECAUSE CENTER
RIGHT PERSON HEADING OVER
TO THE BERKELEY THERE
IS ABSOLUTE VALUE IN HAVING
STRONG DIVERGENT OPINIONS AS
PART OF THE MARKETPLACE OF
ACADEMIC IDEAS BUT WHAT I'M
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
WITH THIS IS THAT WE ARE
CREATING AN ISSUE THAT IS
IN A DIFFERENT JURISDICTION
YOU CAN'T THROUGH ACADEMIC
FREEDOM INSTILL CIVILITY YOU
CAN'T THROUGH ACADEMIC FREEDOM
-- DEBATE -- DEPOLITICIZE
FACEBOOK YOU CAN'T THROUGH
ACADEMIC FREEDOM -- TO
EXPAND ACADEMIC PROTECTIONS
IN A UNIVERSITY SETTING
THAT ALREADY EXIST SO I GUESS
MY POINT IN ALL THIS IS SHOULD
WE JUST BE REINVIGORATING
THE PROVISIONS OF THE UCC
ISSUE AND NUMEROUS PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE BOLD
BLACK -- GRAB SOME PROVISIONS
ON THE IMPORTANCE IN SANCTITY
OF ACADEMIC FREEDOM AS OPPOSED
TO PUSHING YOU KNOW DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION AND IN THE
LATEST SET OF BUZZ WORDS ARE
POLITICAL ATMOSPHERE BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S IMPORTANT
IF I BELIEVE YOU CAN COMMENT
YEAH I'LL TRY TO BRIEFLY FROM
A PERSONAL AYE GROUPS ON THE
SEASON'S ISSUES AT THIS --
PARTICULAR RESOLUTION APPLIES
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
AND I ACTUALLY DO THINK YOU
KNOW LOOK THERE'S A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH OUR SOCIETY TODAY
THIS RESOLUTION DOES NOT SOLVE
ALL THOSE PROBLEMS BUT IT IT
TENDS TO PUSH IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION ON ONE ISSUE WHICH
IS ECONOMIC FREEDOM WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AMONG
EDUCATORS AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE YOU'VE JUST
STATED VERY ELOQUENTLY -- NOW
AND NOW I GUESS I STILL ACTING
CHAIR BORDERS MEAN PORTENTS OF
ECONOMIC FREEDOM IN PROMOTING
DIALOGUE AND AND HELPING TO
FURTHER THE EDUCATION OF OUR
YOUNG STUDENTS SO -- I THINK
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
I AND I DO HOPE IT FURTHERS
IN ADVANCES THE TYPES OF
ABSOLUTE PROTECTION SO YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE I THINK
A LOT OF PROFESSOR PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROFESSORS
MANY OF WHOM ARE ADJUNCTS WHO
HAVE LESS JOB PROTECTIONS THAN
TENURED PROFESSORS THAT YOU
SEASON SEE ISSUES DO FEEL
RELUCTANT TO SPEAK OUT DO
FEEL RELUCTANT TO TEACH THEIR
CLASSES IN A WAY THAT MIGHT
BE PEDAGOGICALLY MOST SOUND
BECAUSE THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE POLITICIZATION OF SPEECH
TODAY OF THE POLITICIZATION OF
THE CLASSROOM -- AND I THINK
IT'S VERY IN A VERY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR BODY -- TO REAFFIRM
VERY LOUDLY OUR STATE THAT THE
ACADEMIC FREEDOM AGAIN IS NOT
GONNA SOLVE ALL PROBLEMS I CAN
SOLVE FACEBOOK BUT IT WILL HELP
PROMOTE BETTER EDUCATION AMONG
OUR CHILDREN THANK YOU FOR
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF
THINGS AND MOVE THE RESOLUTIONS
ARE YOU THANK YOU SURFBOARDS
THANK YOU CENTER WACO SCANNING
THE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
SEEING NONE OF WHICH LIKE
CLOTHES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE AND I APPRECIATE
THE HELP THE DIALOGUE WE NEED
MORE OF THAT HERE AND IN OUR
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS THANK
YOU CENTERMAN MENTERI COUNCIL
THE CALL THE ROLL THANK YOU
THIS IS US SENATE RESOLUTION
FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR MAN THE
MOTION WITH THE MOTION BY CENTER
RIGHT CASKEY THE MOTION IS TO BE
ADOPTED UMBERG FIVE UMBERG AYE
BURGESS THE RUSSELL
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES BLARED
LAYERED I MCGUIRE STERN
BY CAL SKI WHITE HOUSE KIII
WIENER -- SO FAR YOU HAVE
FIVE ALL RIGHT SINCE YOU'RE
THE BILL WAS RESOLUTION
ON CALL THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER YOU ARE HERE ON
THIS J. R. TWELVE NO
SYSTEM THANK YOU FOR BEING
PATIENT FORGERS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS FIFTY
YEARS AGO CONGRESS APPROVED
THE EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT
CONSENTED ON ITS JOURNEY FOR
STATE RATIFICATION UNDER
THE US CONSTITUTION AMENDMENT
NEEDS THIRTY EIGHT STATES TO BE
RATIFIED AND ONCE IT IS RATIFIED
THERE'S THE CONSTITUTION HAS NO
OTHER OTHER REQUIREMENTS OTHER
THAN THAT THIRTY EIGHT STATE
RATIFICATIONS VIRGINIA THE
THIRTY EIGHTH AND FINAL STATE
RATIFIED THE ERA IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY THAT WE FACE
A SITUATION WHERE THE FEDERAL
ARCHIVISTS HASN'T CERTIFIED THAT
RATIFICATION OR PUBLISH THE ERA
CITING A DEADLINE THAT CONGRESS
PUT IN ONE OF THE BILLS
RELATED TO THE ARE NOW
THERE IS AT LEAST ONE AMENDMENT
TO THE CONSTITUTION WHICH
TOOK TWO HUNDRED YEARS FOR
RATIFICATION AND THERE HAVE
NOT BEEN OF THEIR AMENDMENTS
WHERE DEADLINES WERE PUT
THE ERA IS SIMPLE IT'S
LANGUAGE IT BASICALLY ADVANCES
EQUAL JUSTICE FOR WOMEN
GIRLS AND GENDER EXPANSIVE
INDIVIDUALS AND ENSURES THAT
LAWS THAT WOULD
BECAUSE AN UNEQUAL RIGHT FOR
A PERSON OF FEMALE GENDER
THAT THEY COULD BE STRUCK
DOWN IN OTHER WORDS HE GIVES
THE CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTION
WHAT S. J. R. TWELVE DOES IS
IT URGES CONGRESS TO PASS
CONGRESSWOMAN JACKIE SPEARS HR
EIGHT NINETY ONE WHICH DECLARES
THE ERA HAS MET ITS REQUIREMENTS
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION TO
BECOME THE TWENTIETH AMENDMENT
AND IT CALLS ON THE ARCHIVISTS
TO CERTIFY AND PUBLISH THE
RATIFICATION AND LET ME ASK
MY MAIN WITNESS HEATHER SHUMAKER
FROM THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S
LAW CENTER TO -- PERCENT
MISTER MAKER AVAILABLE
I AM SORRY GO
AHEAD THANKS
SENATORS HEATHER SHUMAKER AND
I'M JOINED TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL LAW CENTER THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE Q.
ALL IN SUPPORT OF FINANCIAL
REGULATIONS WELL NATIONAL
ENVELOPE THAT ARE BASED IN
WASHINGTON DC AS A NONPARTISAN
NONPROFIT LEGAL AN ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO THE
ADVANCEMENT AND PROTECTION
OF WOMEN'S LEGAL RIGHTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES APPLE LAWCENTER
THE FIRM ON ALL POINT SINCE
CULTURE AND DRIVE SOLUTION
TO THE GENDER INEQUITY THAT
SHAPE OUR SOCIETY AND TO BREAK
DOWN THE BARRIERS HARMALA
LEGISLATORS THE SOLUTION
PARTICULARLY CRITICAL MOMENT IN
WHICH THE FIFTH HALF IMPACT
OUR ABILITY TO ACHIEVE GENDER
DERAY WOULD AFFIRM GENDER
EQUALITY AT THE CORE PRINCIPLE
OF OUR NATION AND CONGRESS
THE POWER TO PASS LEGISLATION
INTERESTING FACTS IN THE
NATION AND PROVIDE A NEW TOOL
AND A LARGER FIGHTS AGAINST
SEX DISCRIMINATION INCLUDING
AND CHALLENGES THE PREGNANCY
DISCRIMINATION DISCRIMINATION
ON THE BASIS OF GENDER
STEREOTYPES ACTUAL ORIENTATION
DISCRIMINATION GENDER IDENTITY
DISCRIMINATION AND GENDER BASED
VIOLENCE IT'S BEEN TWO YEARS
SINCE THE AREA WAS RATIFIED
BY THIRTY EIGHT IT REMAINS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT IN OUR FIGHT
FOR GENDER JUSTICE FOR ALL
WHILE WE AWAIT A RULING FROM
THE DC CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS
ON WHETHER THE HEARING IS NOW
PART OF THE CONSTITUTION THIS
RESOLUTION COMPETITORS SKINNER
AND ATKINS OF THE CLARION CALL
FOR MEMBERS OF CONGRESS CAN YOU
THE HARD WORK OF IMPLEMENTING
POLICIES THAT FIGHT FOR EQUAL
RIGHTS FOR ALL PEOPLE REGARDLESS
OF GENDER DOING THAT WOULD
BRING US THAT MUCH CLOSER TO
EQUALITY BEFORE THE LAW FOR
ALL PEOPLE OUR GENDERS OPENING
A NEW CHAPTER FOR WOMEN AND
GIRLS MISSION MINE I URGE YOU
TO ADVANCE ITS REPLICATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
MAKER OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OUR PRIMARY WITNESSES SUPPORT
WITNESSES SPORT HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM SINGLE APPROACHING
MICROPHONE ON THE PHONE
MOTOR IF YOU TO HELP THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS J. R.
SKINNER MISTER TWELFTH
THANK YOU PART OF AT
THE J. R. TWELVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
IN ONE AND THEN ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
MR HERE WE HAVE NO SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURN OPPOSITION -- I
DON'T KNOW PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION IF THERE ARE
THOSE IN OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM FEEL APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE SEEING NONE -- MATTER
IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP THOSE
-- ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION
SJR TWELVE I'D BE GRATEFUL
THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AS J. R. TWELVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO CONNECT OPPOSITION
ONE AND THEN ZERO
MISTER CAREY AT NOT POSITION
A QUEUE AT THAT TIME ALL RIGHT
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE SENATE GONZALEZ MOVE THE
BILL SENATE GONZALEZ MOVES
THE BILL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SAYING -- CENTER HERTZBERG YOUR
COUNTRY FROM THE BILL AGENCY
HOUSE BUT I'D CALL THE BILL TO
RESOLUTION RESOLUTION ISSUES
MAY HAVE PRIVILEGES RESOLUTION
MY RECOLLECTION WAS THAT AT THE
TIME STATE SENATOR MERVYN M.
DONNELLY WHO WAS ELECTED
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR AND HE WAS THE
CENTER OF THE TWENTY ESSENTIAL
DISTRICT IS THE ONE WHO ACTUALLY
PAST THIS YEAR'S IMMACULATE
ABOUT THAT WAS LIKE IT MUST'VE
BEEN WITH SEVENTY TWO IS WHEN
THE CONGRESS PASSED BY THE YEARS
MAYBE SEVENTY THREE THAT REGULAR
RECOLLECTION OF THAT RIGHT RIGHT
YES I DIDN'T DO THE HISTORY
OF WHO INTRODUCED IT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO RATIFY IT BUT
THANK YOU YEAH I I THINK THE
GAME CURRICULA REMEMBERS THAT
BACK IN THE DAYS I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE WEEK KNOWLEDGE
CONGRESSMAN LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SENATOR AND
THE TO THE GOVERNOR TIMELY RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGAIN AGAIN
THURSDAY JUNE WE SERVE WITH YES
FOR OUR OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OF BILLS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATE GONZALEZ RESOLUTIONS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATE GONZALEZ
SINCE CAN WOULD LIKE CLOSE
THANK YOU ARMS SENATE BERKSHIRE
I DIDN'T STE I SAID IT SIMPLY
STATES BUT LET ME JUST SAY
HOW SIMPLE IT IS BASICALLY
THE ARE SIMPLY STATES THAT
THE EQUALITY OF RIGHTS UNDER
THE LAW SHALL NOT BE DENIED OR
ABRIDGED BY THE UNITED STATES
OR ANY STATE ON ACCOUNT OF SEX
THAT IS THE ENTIRE --
THERE'S THE ENTIRE AMENDMENT BUT
WHAT IT WOULD DO IS BASICALLY
GIVE GENDER EQUALITY THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL LEGAL STATUS AND
WHEN WE LOOK AT TODAY IN THE U.
S. PURELY BECAUSE OF YOUR SEX
YOU ARE STILL PAID LESS
YOU ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE
PROMOTED AND YOUR MORE SUBJECT
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND THAT
THERE'S DATA THAT SUPPORTS
THAT WE KNOW THAT NOT IT'S
NOT JUST FEMALES THAT ARE
SEXUALLY HARASSED BUT THE DATA
SHOWS THAT YOUR MORE LIKELY SO
WE NEED THE RA --
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU SIR
SKINNER MENTERI CANCER CALDERON
THIS IS SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION
TWELVE BY SENATOR SKINNER
WITH THAT MOTION BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ -- THE MOTION IS TO BE
ADOPTED -- BURKE HI AM BERG BY
POOR JETS THE RUSSELL
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES AIRED
I LAYERED AYE MCGUIRE
STERN BY CAL SKI HI WHAT
KASKY AYE WIENER WIENER AYE
YOU HAVE SIX TO ZERO SO FAR
WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR HERTZBERG
I SPECIAL BILL FOR LA
S. SERVERS FOR ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB NINE ONE THREE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
IS A SPECIAL DEAL FOR LA
ALL RIGHT DID ANYTHING
ELSE TO SAY THAT'S ALL I
BUT BASICALLY IN THAT SHOW
LOOK WE ALL KNOW THAT THE --
ENDEMIC CAUSED SIGNIFICANT
CRISIS FOR SO MANY OF OUR AND
STUFF PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM AND
-- CREDIT YOU JUST VERITIES IN
LOS ANGELES WE HAVE A SERIES
OF LAWS THAT CREATE SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES IN LOS ANGELES
-- YOU KNOW THE DISTRICT HAS
TO HAVE A HAVE A CHILLY TENS OF
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND IN ORDER
TO UTILIZE CERTAIN EXEMPTIONS
SUCH AS SINGLE GENDER CLASSES
THE USE OF SCHOOL PROPERTY THE
TERMS OF EMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
FOR GOVERNING BOARD MEMBERS THIS
MEASURE REDUCES THAT THRESHOLD
FOR FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND BECAUSE
BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC -- THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT EXPERIENCE THE
BEST DROP IN STUDENT ENROLLMENT
LOSING TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS ARE SIX PERCENT OF ITS
TOTAL STUDENT POPULATION JUST
LAST YEAR ALONE SO REDUCING
THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DISTRICT MAINTAINS THE LEVELS
OF PROTECTIONS THAT INFORMED
BY THIS LEGISLATURE AND THIS
GOVERNOR FOR FOR MANY YEARS
WE HAVE DEBORAH BATISTA'S OF
ALLAH AND ALEXANDER MOLINA
FOR THE LOS ANGELES CA AND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IF
ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS OR
WANT TO MAKE A PRESENTATION
BUT -- QUICKLY AND --
ESTERLINE OF THANK YOU THIS
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
-- MISSED THE BALL THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR -- BURKE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF MY NAME IS THAT WHAT ABOUT
THE SIZE OF A LEMON LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WE ARE
TO PLEASED TO SPONSOR THE BILL
SB NINE THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR THE LAST TO GET
DECADES LOS ANGELES UNIFIED HAS
BEEN EXPERIENCING A TREND OF
DECLINING STUDENT ENROLLMENT
MOSTLY DUE TO DECLINING BIRTH
RATES HOUSING UNAFFORDABILITY
AND MIGRATION OF RESIDENTS OUT
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
SCHOOL YEAR ALONE COMPARED TO
LAST YEAR LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
EXPERIENCE A LOSS OF TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE
SIX POINT SIX PERCENT OF OUR
TOTAL STUDENT POPULATION LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED RISKS FALLING
UNDER THE FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
ATA AND WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE
TO OPERATE UNDER THE EXISTING
LAW SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZED
FOR LEDS WITH FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE MORE
WITH ENDLESS UNIFIED VIEWS THE
PROVISIONS OF SB NINE THIRTEEN
S. TECHNICAL CHANGES BUT LOWER
IN THE EIGHTIES THRESHOLD TO
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND EIGHTY
IT WILL ALLOW THE DISTRICT TO
CONTINUE TO UTILIZE STATUTORY
PROVISIONS PERTAINING TO THE
GOVERNANCE AND OPERATIONS OR
SCHOOLS OF WHICH WE HAVE BEEN
OPERATING UNDER FOR DECADES
AS THE LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE SECOND
LARGEST IN THE NATION WE
THERE ARE THERE ARE ECONOMIES OF
SCALE THAT JUSTIFY MAINTAINING
THE CURRENT PROVISIONS FOR
THESE REASON LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED IS SPONSORING SENATE
BILL NINE THIRTEEN IN ORDER
AYE VOTE THANK YOU ARE
FAMOUS WITH THE LAW -- MISTER
MOLINA YOU'RE ON THE PHONE
MODERATORS MISTER ALEXANDER
MOLINA ON THE FULL
A PREVIEW
IT'S FOR A CLEAR FOR THE
HE'S ON THE PHONE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS ALL ALL RIGHT
SO -- OTHERS
MISTER MOLINA MISTER MOLINA
COMBINED NOW THE THREE
OF QUESTIONS WILL WILL
REFER THEM TO HELP MOM
WHEN ARE YOU ON THE LINE
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
CAPTAIN ALEX MOLINA WITH
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT THE OFFICE
THE GENERAL COUNSEL THE NEAR
HERE FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THAT CHRISTMAS MOLINA THAT IS
CORRECT ALL RIGHT OF OTHERS
IN SUPPORT HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM SIGNALED APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE ON THE PHONE
MODERATE A FEW A FEW OF THOSE
IN SUPPORT OF SP NINE ONE THREE
THANK YOU ARE YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE ONE THREE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AND THAT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE SUPPORT
OF AT EIGHT NINE ONE THREE
WHILE WE'RE WAITING I SHOULD
KNOW CENTER HERTZBERG VERY NICE
HERE CUT THANK YOU SIR SHOULD
THEIR STORY THEM WELL HOPEFULLY
DISTORTION WE HAVE THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE AT THE TIME
ALL RIGHT -- LET'S NOW TURN
TO OPPOSITION THOSE IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU'RE OPPOSITION
PLEASE APPROACH A MICROPHONE
SEEING NO ON APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE MADAME MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD TO UP THOSE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB NINE ONE THREE
THANK YOU IN OPPOSITION OF SP
NINE ONE THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO BUT IN THAT ONE
AND THEN THERE UP IN OPPOSITION
UP AT B. NINE ONE THREE
AND WE HAD NO OPPOSITION ACUTE
THANKS ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NONE
OTHER MOTION REMOVED CENTER
LAYERED MOVES THE BILL ALL RIGHT
IT'S LIKE CLOSE SENATORS FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS FRONT OF
OUR BUT YOU CAN ALSO IF
YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS SENATE BILL NINE
THIRTEEN BY CENTER HERTZBERG
WITH EMOTION BY SENATOR
LAYERED THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
-- BURKE AMBERG BY
BURGESS BOARD DECIDED ASAL
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG I'D JONES LAYERED
LAYER TO AYE MCGUIRE
STERN WHITE HOUSE E.
Y. CASKEY AYE WIENER
WIENER HI YOU HAVE TO
SEVEN TWO ZERO SO FAR WITH
MEMBERS MISSING ALL
RIGHT -- PLAYSET BILONG CALL
NEXT WE HAVE CENTER LAYER
CENTER LAYERED SB NINE FOUR
ZERO FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
CENTER LAYERED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISTER CHAIR AND I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
COLLABORATION I SENATE BILL NINE
FORTY ALLOWS LOCALLY ADOPTED
RENT PROTECTIONS TO APPLY TO A
MOBILE HOME SPACES IN EXISTING
AND NEW PARKS BY AMENDING
AN OUTDATED CODE SECTION
THAT PROHIBIT SUCH ACTIVITY
SPECIFICALLY S. B. NINE FORTY
WILL ALLOW SPACES AND PARKS
CREATED IN THE LAST THIRTY YEARS
TO RECEIVE THE PROTECTION OF
LOCALLY PASSED RENT CONTROL WHEN
THE LEASES RENEWED EXTENDED OR
TERMINATED IT ALLOWS SPACES IN
EXISTING PARKS TO IMMEDIATELY
APPLY ANY LOCALLY PASSED RENT
CONTROL AND IT ALLOWS SPACES
CREATED A NEW PARKS TO HAVE
A TEN YEAR EXEMPTION FROM ANY
LOCALLY PASSED RENT CONTROL WELL
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO PASS
ORDINANCES THAT LIMIT THE AMOUNT
PARKS CAN INCREASE TO RESIDENCE
RENT HOWEVER A LAW PASSED IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE EXEMPTS
NEW AND THAT'S IN QUOTES MOBILE
HOME CONSTRUCTION FROM ANY SUCH
LOCAL RENT CONTROL IT --
ARBITRARILY DEFINES NEW MOBILE
HOME CONSTRUCTION AS ANY MOBILE
HOME SPACE INITIALLY OFFERED
FOR RENT ON OR AFTER JANUARY
FIRST NINETEEN NINETY AS A
RESULT CURRENT LAW TREATS MOBILE
HOME SPACES THAT ARE SEVERAL
DECADES OLD AS MUCH AS THIRTY
TWO YEARS OLD AND GROWING
OLDER AS NEW CONSTRUCTION
AS A RESULT NEIGHBORS MAY
PAY VERY DIFFERING AMOUNTS
IN RENT FOR THE SAME BASIC
AMENITIES DEPENDING ONLY ON WHEN
THEIR PARTICULAR SPACES WERE
INCORPORATED INTO THE PARK --
THE OPPOSITION CLAIMS THAT THIS
WILL DISCOURAGE CONSTRUCTION
OF NEW MOBILE HOME SPACES AND
EXACERBATE THE HOUSING CRISIS
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHY TO THE
CONTRARY THIS BILL MAINTAINS AN
INCENTIVE THAT ENCOURAGES NEW
PARK DEVELOPMENT BY OFFERING A
TEN YEAR WINDOW BEFORE ANY
LOCAL RENT CONTROL PLIES THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO TARA THE TIME
TO RECOVER THEIR COSTS IT STILL
GRANTS LANDLORDS BROAD AUTHORITY
TO RAISE RENTS OVER THE TEN YEAR
WINDOW AND RECOUP THEIR CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS THE BILL STRIKES
A REASONABLE AND FAIR BALANCE
OF ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO GOVERN AFFORDABILITY FOR
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS AND
THE CREATION OF NEW UNITS
IT'S CRITICAL LEGISLATION
FOR ENSURING CALIFORNIANS
LIVING IN MOBILE HOME PARK
COMMUNITIES ARE PROTECTED FROM
LARGE UNFORESEEN RENDON CREASES
WITHOUT DIMINISHING PROPERTY
OWNERS ABILITY TO MAKE A FAIR
RETURN ON THEIR INVESTMENT AND
MOBILE HOME PARKS ARE DIFFERENT
BECAUSE PEOPLE DO NOT OWN THE
UNDERLYING SPACE THE IPHONE
OVER IT THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT
RELATIONSHIP THAN EXISTS IN
CONVENTIONAL HOUSING RENTALS
-- ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY WITH
ME TODAY IS BRUCE STANTON THE
LEGAL COUNSEL FROM THE GOLDEN
STATE MANUFACTURED HOMEOWNERS
SLEEK AND STEPHEN JONES THE
PRESIDENT OF THE GOLDEN STATE
MANUFACTURED HOME OWNERS LAKE
CHAPTER SIX EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FOUR AND A RESIDENT OF A
MOBILE HOME PARK IN OHIO --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FAST FOR
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU CENTER
LAYERED MR STAND IF YOU'RE WITH
US PLEASE ANNOUNCE YOURSELF
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS
FLORIDA HAS BEEN GENERAL COUNSEL
FOR GSM WELL IT'S SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT THE BILL DOES INDEED
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNANCE HOMEOWNER
AFFORDABILITY AND THE CREATION
OF NEW MOBILE HOME PARKS
AND ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DISCRETION TO GOVERN THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION EXEMPTION LOCAL
PROBLEM RENT CONTROL FOR ANY
BELIEVE BUILT SPACES AFTER
NINETEEN NINETY HAS REMAINED
UNCHANGED FOR THIRTY TWO YEARS
DECADE OLD EXEMPTION WOULD
INTENDED TO INCENTIVIZE YOU
PARKING STRUCTURE BUT DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSE BIRDS IT'S REALLY HAD
NO EFFECT ONLY ONE POINT
FIVE PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA
MOBILE HOME PARKS HAVE BEEN
BUILT SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
REPRESENTING ONE POINT FOUR
PERCENT OF ALL MOBILE HOME
SPACES ONLY FOURTEEN PARKS AND
SIXTEEN HUNDRED SPACES HAVE
BEEN FILLED SINCE THE YEAR
TWO THOUSAND AND BILL TO PARKS
BILL SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN
WHAT WILL HAPPEN SHOULD NOT
BE SACRIFICED FOR SUPPOSED
INCENTIVE WHICH TIME THE DATA
HAVE PROVED EFFECTIVE WITH
THIS BILL ALLOWS NEW PART
DEVELOPERS OF ROLLING TEN
YEAR OPPORTUNITY TO RECOUP
INVESTMENT COSTS CURRENTLY
A SPACES BUILT SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY REMAIN EXEMPT FROM LOCAL
RENT PROTECTION THIS INCLUDES
NEW SPACES ADDED TO EXISTING
PARKS READING THE ARTICLE
SITUATION WHERE ONE SPACE BUILT
BEFORE NINETEEN NINETIES RAP
PROTECTED WHILE THE DAYBREAK
BELIEVE FILL SPACE IN THE SAME
PARKING LOT THE BILL ADDRESSES
THIS INEQUALITY BY PROTECTING
ALL STATIONS THAT INTERFERING
WITH EXISTING RENTAL AGREEMENTS
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY REMAINS
CALIFORNIA'S TOP ISSUE WITH
MOBILE HOMES ONE OF ITS LAST
FOUR MONTHS OF THIS BILL ENSURES
THEY CAN'T REPAIR AFFORDABLE
ELIMINATING THIS LOOPHOLE
ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
GOVERN WITHIN THEIR DISCRETION
THE BILL DOES NOT DICTATE TERMS
BY WHICH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO MAKE DECISIONS SIMPLY
PRIORITIZES THE PROTECTION OF
HOMEOWNERS CHOICE TO PRESERVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BEFORE MORE
OCCUPANTS ARE PRICED OUT OF
THEIR HOUSE WE FEEL THE AGENT
EFFECTIVE LOOPHOLE SHOULD
CONTINUE NO LONGER WE ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
MISS STANDS NEXT MISTER JONES
MR JOHNSON AVAILABLE
FOR WAITING FOR MISTER JONES
-- WHEN YOU REACH A CERTAIN
AGE IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THE WISDOM -- THAT IS ACCRUED
OVER THE YEARS OF LEGISLATIVE
SERVICE AND IN THAT VEIN
WE WISH CENTER EARLIER TO
HAPPY BIRTHDAY HAPPY BIRTHDAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WISH
MY WITNESS HAD BEEN ON TIME
JOHN ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR US
YES THAT'S THE CONSEQUENCE
MISTER JONES ARE YOU AVAILABLE
ALL RIGHT THIS
ONE MOMENT PLEASE
ONE MOMENT GOOD
FOR YOU ONE MOMENT
LET ME OPEN HIS LINE ONE MOMENT
BUT THE DANTE ABLE TO HEAR UP
YES I CAN HEAR YOU CAN HEAR
ME YES THANK YOU MISTER
JONES GO AHEAD HELLO MISTER
JOHNSON WE CAN HEAR YOU GO
OKAY THANK YOU YEAH STEVEN JONES
AND I'M PRESIDENT OF THAT GET
SMALL CHAPTER EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FOUR LIVE IN OKAY THE MOBILE
HOME PARK WHICH IS A SENIOR PARK
BUILT AFTER NINETEEN NINETY AND
ALTERNATE AND SENIORS LIVING
IN A MOBILE HOME PARK WITH
MODESTLY AND WITHOUT STABILIZE
RATES WE'RE SEEING INCREASES
THAT ARE NOT SUSTAINABLE
OUR COUNTY GOVERNMENT RESPONDED
IN VOTED TO PROTECT SENIORS
LIKE US BUT BECAUSE OF THE
STATE IMPOSED POLL THAT THAT
STILL ADDRESSES WE ARE NOT
COVERED LOCAL ORDINANCES ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO FULLY COVERED FOR ME
ACTUAL GOVERNMENTS DO EVERYTHING
IN THEIR POWER TO ADDRESS THE
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS MAKE
TO YOU WE SHOULD MAKE IT CAL
AND W. O. O. PARKS ALLOWING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO GOVERN
ON THE ISSUE OF PORTABILITY IS
NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE IN FACT
THE LEGISLATURE AS RECENTLY
PASSED LEGISLATION TO CREATE
NEW AND DIFFERENT INCENTIVES TO
BUILDING ALONG PARKS WHICH WE
SUPPORT WE SUPPORT VIDEOS
INCENTIVES TO BUILD NEW PARKS
BECAUSE OF THE INCENTIVES DID
NOT MAKE IT CONTINGENT ON COULD
COMPROMISE THE PORTABILITY AND
COOKING -- CENTER HOMES RISK
NOTHING UNITS BILL PRINCIPLE
HOME PARKS OR NEW SPACES FROM
THE TRUCK IN FACT THERE'S A
ROLLING PIN YOUR IT EXCEPTION
FOR INVESTORS TO CONTINUE
BUILDING NEW PARKS SENATE ALERT
HAS A SOLUTION TO KEEP PEOPLE
LIKE ME IN THEIR HOMES AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS ON THE
PAST NINE FORTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER JONES ALL RIGHT
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
SAYING NO ON APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONES MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD TO
UP THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE FOUR ZERO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FOUR ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AGAIN
THAT IS ONE THEN PICK UP YOUR
AND THE PORTS OF AT THE NINE
FOUR ZERO AND WE WILL
ABOUT EIGHTEEN KILLED MISTER
CHAIR OF ALL GO TO LINE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ALL RIGHT FOR NINE
THIRTY FIVE FOR THOSE
IN Q. -- YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU WILL GO ON TO
LINE FIFTEEN ALLIANCE
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI MY NAME IS MONEY THAT YOU
CANNOT I REPEAT FAN FICS I
THINK YOU COULD DO THAT ON AND
I'M UP WITH THE MANAGER FORM OF
OKAY THEY MANUFACTURE HOME OWNER
PLEASE I'M IN FAVOR THANK YOU
THANK YOU NETWORK TO LINE
UP FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HI MY NAME IS MERRY GO
BARRICADES ARE YOU EVEN
REAL BEACH FRANK BAILEY AND
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND I SUPPORT
SB NINE FORTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU LINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
PICTURE PICTURE MY NAME IS
LORI GREINER I LIVE IN THE CITY
OWNS MOBILE HOME PARK IN AURORA
GRANDE AND I SUPPORT AT C. NINE
FORTY THANK YOU CONSTITUENTS
THANK YOU I TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
BY TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN
AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO LIKE
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
MY NAME IS LINDA TEN
MEN I LET THE MAKES A
DIFFERENCE LOCAL PARK IN
AURORA GRANDE AND I SUPPORT
SB NINE FORTY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
LEVINE SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN
OKAY WE WILL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
BY SEVENTY THREE
ALIGN AT THE OPEN
YOU HAVE A SEND YOU
I DIDN'T RECEIVE A LINE NUMBER
BUT I WILL SPEAK MY NAME IS
ANDREA MAY FEEL I LIVE IN
RANCHO BUENA VISTA MOBILE
HOME PARK IN SANTA MARIA
AND I SUPPORT SB NINE FORTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE ONE IN
Q. AND WE'RE JUST GIVING THEM
MY NUMBER ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE AT
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
I DIDN'T RECEIVE THE LINE NUMBER
BUT MY NAME IS SHARON MCMAHON
I LIVE IN MESA DUNES MOBILE
HOME PARK IN AURORA GRANDY
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT FIFTY
NINE FORTY THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND THAT WAS
ELECTRONIC YOU ALL RIGHT --
I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE TO IN
THIS IS IN OPPOSITION -- MISTER
BAKER AND MISTER WHAT KOWSKI
IT APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
CAST ASIDE MISTER WEISSACH
WELL FIRST OF ALL I'M HONORED
TO BE CALLED MISTER WHITE
CASKEY SAID THE SAME FAMILY
JUST LITTLE DIFFERENT SPELLINGS
THAT'S ALL RIGHT SO I AM
SENATOR HAPPY BIRTHDAY SO
WHAT BETTER GIFT CAN I GIVE
TO THEM TO OPPOSE HER BELT
-- BUT WITH WITH WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO IT SINCE THIS IS
BEEN HM INTERESTING HEARING
WE STARTED OUT WITH TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE TALKING ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF CREATING MORE
HOUSING UNFORTUNATELY WE BELIEVE
THAT W. MAYES AT THIS BILL WILL
ABSOLUTELY DO THE OPPOSITE
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
HOUSING CRISIS WILL WE NEED
TO DO IS CREATE MORE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES UNLIKE AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THAT WAS
PASSED JUST A FEW YEARS AGO
WHICH GRANTED APARTMENTS A
FIFTEEN YEAR RETURN AND DID NOT
RETROACTIVELY CAPTURE UNITS THIS
BILL RETROACTIVELY IMPOSES
RENT CONTROL ON THOUSANDS OF
NEW HUMBLE MOBILE HOME SPACES
BUILT AFTER NINETEEN NINETY
AND WON'T ALLOW ANY RETURN FOR
NEW SPACES BUILT AFTER JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE
WE HAVE OVER FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
PARKS IN THE STATE IF EVERY
PARK BUILT FIVE TWO SPACES
THAT'S TWENTY THOUSAND NEW
ROOFS OVER HEADS IF THIS
BILL PASSES ALMOST NONE AT
THE SPACES WOULD BE BUILT
THIS BILL CHANGES THE RULES
AFTER THE GAMES BEGUN AT
LEAST UNDER áP FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO RENT CONTROL FOR
APARTMENTS WAS EXEMPT FROM
RENT CONTROL FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS ON A PROSPECTIVE BASIS
THE RETROACTIVE NATURE THIS
BILL IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE ABOUT THIS
LEGISLATION UNDER S. B. NINE
FORTY THE STATE IS GOING BACK
ON ITS WORD TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING IF THIS BILL BECOMES
LAW WHY WOULD ONE SPACE BE
BUILT HOW CAN PARK OWNERS
MAKE DECISIONS TO BUILDING
SPACES IF THEY KNEW THE
RULES CAN BE CHANGED IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE GAME CONSUMER
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A WMA
MEMBER WHO IS IN THE PROCESS OF
ADDING SIXTY SEVEN NEW SPACES
UNDER THIS BILL THE FUTURE
IS DISMAL PARKS HAVE LAND
WITH SPACE TO BUILD WE'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A HOUSING
CRISIS IN S. B. NINE FORTY --
CLOSE THE DOOR ON THOSE WHO
NEED MORE ATTAINABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS ACROSS THE STATE
THIS IS ALL HAPPENING AT
THE SAME TIME THE GOVERNOR'S
ALLOCATING FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO PURCHASE PARKS FOR
RESIDENTS IF THIS BILL PASSES
THE PRICE OF THOSE PURCHASES
WILL DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
THE STATE WE BELIEVE SHOULD
INCENTIVIZE AND ENCOURAGE MORE
HOUSING OPTIONS IT SHOULDN'T
END THE MANUFACTURED HOUSING
AS AN OPTION FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
THESE REASONS THAN THOSE LISTED
IN OUR LETTER WE RESPECTFULLY
SENATOR LAYERED AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MUST OPPOSE
YOUR BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER WYSOCKI MISTER WALKER
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AT CHASE AND I OCCURRED --
WITH ADULTS DEAN GILBERT
ROBESON'S SMITH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE ALL ECHO THE
BIRTHDAY WISHES TO THE SENATOR
-- THE L. A. I. I WILL DO MY
BEST NOT TO REPEAT MR WHY
SAKI'S TESTIMONY THE THE THE
RENT CONTROL EXEMPTION THAT
WE'RE DEBATING IN THIS BILL
TODAY HAS BEEN REFERRED TO
AS A LOOPHOLE AND FROM THE
PERSPECTIVES OF C. MPAS MEMBERS
WE DO IT IS REALLY THE LAST
INCENTIVE FROM THE STATE TO
BUILD OUT AND THAT WAS WHAT
MISTER WYSOCKI WAS REFERRING
TO THE MOBILE HOME PARKS ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT FROM
APARTMENTS AND A LOT OF WAYS
AND AND AND ONE WAY IS THAT
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO BUILD
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF APARTMENT
UNITS EVERY YEAR IN THE YEAR
WE DON'T HAVE A A NET LOSS OF
SPACES IN MOBILE HOME PARKS WE
MIGHT BUILD TENS OR HUNDREDS
-- AND AGAIN YOU KNOW AS AS
IT'S BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED BY THE
PROPONENTS AND ACKNOWLEDGED BY
THE AUTHOR WE WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE PEOPLE HOUSE MOBILE
HOME PARK SO IT'S NOT JUST THE
VALUE OF MY CLIENT BECAUSE OF
SELF INTEREST IT'S BEEN THE
LONG STANDING VALUE OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS COMMITTEE
-- BUT TO PUT PUT THINGS
YOU KNOW SIMPLY WITHOUT THIS
EXEMPTION THE PARK OWNERS THAT
WE REPRESENT THE ONES THAT
HAVE TO MAKE THE INVESTMENTS TO
ACTUALLY BUILD OUT NEW SPACES
AND EXPAND THEIR PARKS THEY
DON'T FEEL THAT THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE THE CERTAINTY NECESSARY
TO DO THAT FOR THOSE REASONS
-- WERE UNFORTUNATELY -- WE
HAVE TO BE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER JUST A NOTE I WANT TO
MAKE MISTER WYSOCKI FEEL BETTER
BY MISPRONOUNCING YOUR NAME
AS WELL SO OUR PLACES
-- ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM SEEING NONE ARE ON THE
PHONE BUT IF YOU TWO OF THOSE
ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
ONE BEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
OPPOSITION ONE NINE
ZERO AND WE DO HAVE
A COUPLE YEAR QUEUING UP
JUST A MINUTE
ONCE AGAIN THAT IS IN OPPOSITION
WE WILL GO DOWN THE LINE
YOUR FIFTY FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FIFTY SIX
YES -- GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CORINNE
GREASY ON THE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING
OF OF THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE IN THE QUEUE
AND IF THAT WILL BE HERE AND
I THINK IT NEVER LINE NUMBER
-- ABLE ABLE TO LINE NUMBER
FIFTY EIGHT EIGHT FOUR HAD
HI MY NAME IS MARYLAND GREEN AND
I AM -- WITH PLANTATION ON THE
LAKE WHICH IS A FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SEVEN BEAUTIFUL
MANUFACTURED HOME COMMUNITY
AND CALIMESA CALIFORNIA WHEN
WE BOUGHT THE PARK IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX NO MATTER WHAT YOU
HUNDRED EIGHTY MA'AM GO HEAD
JUST STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
OKAY MY NAME IS MARYLAND
GREEN -- I'M WITH PLANTATION
ON THE LAKE -- HI I'M
REPRESENT THE OWNERS AND
-- WE HAVE FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN ARE YOU FAMILIAR
FASTER IN YOUR YOUR POST
YOUR POST OF THE BILL
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO LET'S
GO NOW IS ANOTHER CALLER
NO OTHER CALLERS MODERATOR
ANYONE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE IN OPPOSITION
THERE IS NO OTHER IN THE QUEUE
FOR OPPOSITION AS OF RIGHT
NOW ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE CENTER BOARD JUST
THANK YOU CHAIR I HAVE
-- SUPPORTED A NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES BILLS IT OF LATE
AND -- I SO I THINK WITH
THERE'S A FIRST MORE COMMON
GROUND THAN ONE MIGHT EXPECT
-- THIS ISSUE HOWEVER
IS NOT ONE OF THEM AND
I'M TRYING TO MAKE SENSE
THERE SEEMS TO BE A DRAMATIC
INTERNAL INCONSISTENCY HERE
MEANING THAT I WON LEVEL YOU
WANT TO DELEGATE IN RESPECT
LOCAL CONTROL WHEN MATTERS
ARE WITHIN THE JURISDICTION
OF LOCAL AUTHORITIES BUT IF
THOSE LOCAL AUTHORITIES ARE
NOT DOING THINGS THE WAY THAT
YOU WISH TO BE DONE THEN THE
STRONG ARM OF THE STATE NEEDS
TO STEP IN IN THIS SITUATION
YOU'RE DIPPING YOUR TOES INTO
POND SIMULTANEOUSLY YOU'RE
REMOVING LOCAL CONTROL WHEN
YOU DON'T LIKE THE RESULT AND
THEN YOU'RE GOING TO OVERRIDE
LOCAL CONTROL AFTER TEN YEAR
TIME PERIOD OF TIME AFTER
CONSTRUCTION NEW CONSTRUCTION IS
BUILT SO THIS REALLY IS
KIND OF A HODGE PODGE --
THAT THE RESULT YOU WANT
IS ALREADY DETERMINED IN YOU'RE
TRYING TO FIND THE RATIONALE TO
REVERSE ENGINEER AND I'M
FINDING THAT THIS IS REALLY
GOING TO CREATE NOT ONLY MORE
CONFUSION THE MARKET PLACE
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE INDIVIDUALS
THINKING THEY HAVE A WINDOW
OF TEN YEARS WITHIN WHICH TO
BUILD AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT INVESTMENT -- BUT WAIT
YOU KNOW LIKE AN INFOMERCIAL
THERE'S MORE YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO MAKE THE
MONEY THAT YOU PROJECTED OUT
WHICH IS THE UNDERPINNING OF
MAKING THE INVESTMENT TO BEGIN
WITH SO I'M REALLY
HAVING A HARD TIME WITH THIS
ONE FOLKS IF WE DO BELIEVE
IN HOUSING THEN WE NEED TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT HOUSING IS
SOMETHING WE PUT AS A PRIORITY
AND MAKE IT EASY FOR FOLKS TO DO
IF WE BELIEVE THAT RENT CONTROL
IN LOCAL AUTHORITY IS SOMETHING
THAT WE BELIEVE IN THEM ALLOW
THAT TO HAPPEN BUT THIS HODGE
PODGE IS GOING TO HAVE THE
EXACT UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
THAT YOU ACTUALLY WANT IN MY
IN MY OPINION I THINK -- WE
HAVE SEEN THAT MOBILE HOMES
HAVE BEEN ATTACKED FOR THE
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS AND I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IS IT
REALLY BASED ON HOUSING WARS
BECAUSE IN CERTAIN INSTANCES
LOCAL AUTHORITIES HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED -- TO CRAFT EXEMPTIONS
BECAUSE THEY WITH THEIR WISDOM
OF THEIR ENVIRONMENT IN THE
INSIGHTS OF THEIR COMMUNITY
DEEM THIS IMPORTANT -- TO KEEP
FOLKS INVESTING AND REINVESTING
-- FOR HOUSING PURPOSES SO
I'M ABSOLUTELY BEFUDDLED WITH
THE LOGIC OF THIS OF THIS
BILL -- -- -- I WON'T BE IN A
POSITION TO SUPPORT IT BUT I
I REALLY DO ASK MY COLLEAGUES
IF THEY REALLY WANT TO LOOK AT
HOUSING WHAT DIRECTION WE WANT
TO GO TO THE WANT RENT CONTROL
OR DO THEY WANT -- TO INSPIRE
HOUSING -- IF YOU WANT TO
INSPIRE HOUSING YOU CAN'T
REVERT BACK TO LOCAL -- --
BRING CONTROLS JUST PICK A SIDE
WAS THAT A QUESTION
OKAY THEN I'LL ANSWER MY
CLOTHES MISTER CHARGES
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY KASKI
I THINK I THINK I UNDERSTAND
THE RENT CONTROL PORTIONS AND
WHY YOU HAVE TO TEN YEAR PERIOD
THERE IN THE PARAGRAPHS ABOUT
THE DISPARITY BETWEEN DIFFERENT
OWNERS MAKES SENSE I'M GONNA
GO BACK TO THE CONSTRUCTION
BECAUSE BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION'S
A LETTER SISTERS VIRTUALLY BEEN
NO CONSTRUCT NEW MOBILE HOME
PARKS BUILT IN SIXTY YEARS ARE
YOU WITNESSES SAYS THAT IN THE
LAST THIRTY TWO YEARS SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY THE SPACES HAVE
INCREASED BY ONE AND A HALF
PERCENT SO IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THAT IF YOU'RE INTERESTED
IN BUILDING A MOBILE HOME PARK
AND YOU HAD CARP LAUNCHED TO
BILLS AND CHARGE WHATEVER RIGHT
YOU WANTED TO BECAUSE OF THE
THE PROPONENTS CHARACTERIZATION
THAT THEY THINK THEY DON'T
THEY'RE NOT COVERED BY ANY
LOCAL RENT CONTROL SO I GET
THAT YOU GOT A CITY THAT HAS
RENT CONTROL BUT I COME IN WITH
A NEW MOBILE HOME PARK I'M NOT
SUBJECT TO THAT EVEN WITH THAT
NOBODY IS BUILDING A NEW MOBILE
HOME PARKS THAT WOULD MEAN THAT
THERE'S VIRTUALLY HAS BEEN NO
MOBILE HOME PARKS BUILT IN THIS
THIRTY TWO YEARS SAID IT'S BEEN
ANYTHING GOES SO HOW DOES
PUTTING THE TENURE RECOVERY
LIMIT ON THAT ACCELERATE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF PARKS I KNOW
WHAT THAT'S WHAT IT DOES
BUT I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
IT TO THE I GUESS IT'S THE
OPPOSITION IF YOU REALLY WANT
IF YOU WANT RENT CONTROL I GET
THAT BUT JUST ON BUILDING THE
PARKS HOW WOULD ANYBODY DO THAT
BUT THEY HAVEN'T DONE IT ALREADY
HELLO I I'M GONNA TAKE
THAT IS A QUESTION THAT
WAS A CITIZEN RIGHT
OKAY IS BECAUSE THE --
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
CONSTRUCTING APARTMENTS AND
CONSTRUCTING MOBILE HOME
PARKS BECAUSE IN APARTMENTS OR
HOMES IT'S THE FULL DEAL
YOUR YOUR WALLS ROOFS THE WHOLE
BUSINESS IF YOUR MOBILE HOME
PARK YOUR CONSTRUCTING HOOK
UPS AND SPACES AND THE MOBILE
HOME IS BROUGHT IN AND OWNED
BY THE INDEPENDENT TENET AND
SO IF THERE'S A FIFTEEN YEAR
AS WELL AS TALK THROUGH THAT
MAY WELL BE APPROPRIATED FOR
BUILDINGS THE ENTIRE THING BUT
IF YOUR -- DOING A PAD
BUILDING HOOK UPS A TEN YEAR
RECOVERY IS A FAIR RATE OF
RETURN AND A LOGICAL TIME
TO RECOVER THAT I MEAN
I'M TALKING VOLUME I'M SAYING
IN THIRTY TWO YEARS OF THE
YEAR WITNESSES SENSORS ONLY
ONE RIDER SENATE IT GETS TO
THE PREVIOUS COMMENT TO IN A
COUPLE OF VOICE AND AND ONE IS
TO MAKE A CLEAR POINT BECAUSE IT
MADE IT SOUND LIKE RENT CONTROL
WAS BEING OPPOSED IMPOSE FROM
THE STATE BY THIS IS A LOCAL
CHOICE THAT MANY OF THESE
SPACES DON'T HAVE RENT CONTROL
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN A LOCAL
CHOICE OF THAT GOVERNMENT NOT
TO HAVE MOBILE HOME RENT CONTROL
THIS IS NOT AN IMPOSITION OF
IT THIS IS THE FACT THAT
OF THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF MOBILE HOME PARKS IN
HER SPACE IS IN CALIFORNIA
NINETY EIGHT POINT FIVE PERCENT
COULD BE COVERED BY RENT
CONTROL IF THERE IS A LOCAL
RENT CONTROL ORDINANCE IN PLACE
ONE AND A HALF PERCENT OR NOT
BECAUSE OF SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
ONE WAY PASSED THE BILL
THE TO REALIZE THE RATE OF
RETURN CAUSE FOR THE NINETY
EIGHT AND A HALF PERCENT IT
IS BEEN A HISTORIC SOCIAL BARK
THAT THERE IS A FAIR RATE
OF RETURN THAT BECAUSE
THE INVESTMENT AND CAUSTIC
CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN THE
PARK IN THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
HOSTAGES BECAUSE THEY OWN A
MOBILE HOME PARK AND IF THEY
WERE YOU AFFECTED THEIR STOCK
BECAUSE THEY OWN THE THING ON
TOP OF THE SPACE AND IT GIVES
THEM PROTECTION ON THE OTHER
PLACE AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT IS FIXED THAT WORKS FOR
NINETY EIGHT AND A HALF PERCENT
OF THE SPACES AND MORE AND
WHEN THIS WAS ENACTED THIRTY
TWO YEARS AGO I DON'T THINK
IT WAS TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT
THAT ANYTHING CONSTRUCTED IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE WOULD BE
CONSIDERED NEW IN PERPETUITY AS
LONG SINCE AS THE RATE OF RETURN
AND THE VALUE BEEN RECOVERED BY
ANYBODY THAT INTERESTED IN THAT
PERIOD THIS CATCHES IT UP BUT
HAS YOU POINTED OUT THERE HASN'T
BEEN A NEW ONE IN NINE YEARS
THEREFORE THE OF THE ONE AND A
HALF PERCENT THAT ARE COVERED
THERE'S PROBABLY A LIKELIHOOD
THAT THEY'LL FALL AT THE RATE OF
RETURN ARE COME BACK TO
THEM REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THIS LAW PASSES HERE TODAY
AND I STILL THINK THERE'S THE
INCENTIVE THERE BUT THE REASON
IT HASN'T BEEN CONSTRUCTED IN
MANY WAYS FOR REASONS THAT ARE
WAY BEYOND THIS BILL AND IT IT
IS LAND COST IT IS MANY
OTHER THINGS AND IF WE'RE GOING
TO ADDRESS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO IT IN OTHER WAYS THIS
IS ABOUT CATCHING UP THE LAW
TO TO SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
ALL RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YES ST JOHN'S
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
DON'T KNOW MISTER CHAIR IF THE
AUTHOR I WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER
THIS OR THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MIGHT WANT ANSWERED
OR MAYBE BOTH TAKE A STAB AT
IT BUT AS HAS BEEN STATED
-- INAL YOU KNOW SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY THERE THERE HAVEN'T BEEN
WHAT WHAT ONE NEW PARK BUILT
WHICH I ANY RATHER IT HAD BEEN
ONE -- HOWEVER MANY NEW PARKS
AND FOURTEEN FOURTEEN NEW PARK
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY YES OKAY
SO ACTUALLY SAID THAT SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SO IT'S PROBABLY
MORE THAN THAT OKAY -- I
I HAVE SHOWN AND -- SUPPORT
FOR RENT CONTROL AND -- MOBILE
HOME PARKS IN THE PAST MY
HOME TOWN HAS AN ORDINANCE
A COUPLE OF THE OTHER CITIES
IN MY DISTRICT DO SOME OF THE
CITY'S DON'T SO IT'S MAKES
JUST LIKE YOU EXPLAINED --
AND YOU KNOW THE REASONS FOR MY
SUPPORT OF RENT CONTROL MOBILE
HOME PARKS IS IS NOT A MARKET
SITUATION IT'S YOU KNOW THE
THE TENANTS ARE TRAPPED IN YOU
KNOW TO SOME DEGREE FOR LACK
OF A BETTER TERM ON THE LAND
THAT THEY'RE RENTING AND --
YOU KNOW MANY OF THESE HOMES
A STATE LAW HAS IS THEY'RE OLD
ENOUGH TO STAY ALIVE DOESN'T
ALLOW THEM TO BE MOVED IF
THERE WAS A NEW PARK TO OPEN
UP FOR THEM FOR THERE TO BE
A COMPETITIVE MARKET SO YOU
KNOW I I THINK THE BEST
-- SITUATION FOR OWNERSHIP OF
THE PARKS IS EITHER FOR THE
PARKS THE RESIDENTS THAT RENT
THE SPACES TO OWN THE PARK
OR FOR THE PARK OWNER THAT
OWNS THE PARK TO ALSO OWN
THE HOMES SO THAT EVERYTHING
CAN BE ON AN EQUAL PLAYING
GROUND A AND A FREE MARKET --
UNFORTUNATELY IN MANY CASES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S NOT
THE CASE SO -- WE'VE COME UP
WITH AN IDEA TO PROTECT
THE HOMEOWNERS --
AND -- AND HOPEFULLY GIVE A RATE
OF RETURN TO THE PARK OWNERS
MY QUESTION IS OF THE PARKS
THAT HAVE OPENED UP SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY THE RESIDENTS
MOVING IN THEIR HOMES INTO
THOSE PARKS WOULD KNOW
THAT THEY'RE NOT PROTECTED BY
BREAKING TROLL AND THAT THEIR
SPACE IS GONNA BE AT MARKET
RATE WHATEVER THAT MARKET
RATE IS INFERTILITY -- AS
LONG AS THEY ON THAT MARKET SO
-- WHAT'S IS THERE A
COMMON OR AIM I MORE
WHAT'S BEEN THE
THE AGREEMENT SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY THE MOST COMMON AGREEMENT
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY BETWEEN
THE PARK OWNERS AND THE
RESIDENTS THAT ARE MOVING THEIR
HOMES INTO THOSE NEW PARKS
ARE WOULD HAVE TO DEFER TO
THE WITNESSES BECAUSE I'M NOT
A HUNDRED PERCENT SURE THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION --
IT WOULD THAT BE OKAY MISTER
CHAIR FOR THE WITNESSES DANCER
NOT SURE THANK YOU I THINK
I DON'T THINK THE PROCREATE
WOULD BE THE PARK OWNERS
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S THE
ONE TAKE A SHOT AT THAT --
MR BY SAKE CAN ANSWER
THAT BE GREAT --
IN A LETTER BUT I ALSO THINK IT
BE APPROPRIATE FOR A YEAR YOUR
SPONSOR ANSWERS WELL BUT FROM
OUR STANDPOINT THIS IS ABOUT
SPACES THIS IS AN ABOUT PARKS
SPACES CONSTRUCTED SHOULD
BE EXEMPT FROM STATEWIDE
RENT CONTROL THEY SHOULD BE
GRANDFATHERED IN UNDER THE
EXISTING RULES AND REGULATIONS
THAT ARE ALREADY IN PLACE
WE WANT TO BUILD MORE SPACES
THIS BILL UNDER A STARTING
IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE WILL
PREVENT THE ABILITY FOR OUR
PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY INCREASE
THE SIZE OF THEIR ACTUAL PARKS
ARE YOU SAYING NEWS I'M SORRY
ARE YOU SAYING NEW SPACES IN
EXISTING PARKS NEW SPACES IN
EXISTING PARKS HIS THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
HERE OKAY BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
ABILITY TO EXPAND WE'VE GOT
SPACE IN A LOT OF OUR PARKS
WE'VE GOT MAYBE TWENTY THOUSAND
SPACES THAT COULD BE BUILT
OVER NIGHT BUT THE DIFFERENCES
IT TAKES UNLIKE AN APARTMENT
BUILDING WHERE WE CAN BE FULLY
OCCUPIED ON DAY ONE AND OF
THE CERTIFICATE OF OCCUPANCY
WE HAVE TO GREAT WE HAVE TO
PLAN WE HAVE TO ELECTRIFY
AND WE HAVE TO ACTUALLY GET
THE SPACE SEN IT OFTEN TAKES
SIX TO EIGHT MONTHS FIRST
SINGLES -- SINGLE HOME TO
ACTUALLY BE PUT INTO A PARK
AND IS IS IS THE MOST COMMON
EXPERIENCE WITH THAT WITH
THOSE NEW SPACES IS THE PARK
OWNER OWNING THE MOBILE HOME THE
THE HOME ALSO OR IS THE PARK
OWNER RENTING THAT SPACE OUT TO
SOMEBODY WHO MOVES A HOME ON TO
THE SPACE USUALLY IT'S THE PARK
OWNER INSTEAD RENTS RENTS
THE SPACE A HOME IS BROADBAND
GOTCHA OKAY THANK YOU SO AND IN
A SENSE IF THE WITNESSES SUPPORT
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A SHOT I WAS
GONNA ASK MISTER STANTON IF YOU
HAD A COMMENT TO ASK THROUGH THE
CHAIR IT'S OKAY WITH THE CHAIR
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME I'D
BE HAPPY TO YES WE CAN
YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE IF WE'RE TALKING HERE
ABOUT THE CONSTRUCTION OF IS
SPACES THE WAY THAT THAT CANIKLI
WORKS IN MY EXPERIENCE OF
EPISODE I AGING AND SPECIALIZING
IN MOBILE ONLINE BIGGEST
INDUSTRIES THAT THE BID BY TI
EIGHTY THE WAY THAT TYPICALLY
WORKS IS THE PARK OWNERS
RESPONSIBLE TO CERTAINLY GREAT
THE SPACE RECOUP WHATEVER
BRASSER TREAT YOUR PROPERTY
AREA THEY'RE FIVE FEET IT'S
ABOUT BEING TURNED INTO A BATTLE
SPACE SOMETIMES IN FACT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS TAKING EXISTING
SPACES AND JUST MOVING HOLES
CLOSER TOGETHER SO THERE'S SOME
GRADING THERE THERE CERTAINLY
MAY BE A CONCRETE PAD THAT
NEEDS TO BE CORD AND THERE
ARE UTILITIES THAT NEED TO BE
INSTALLED BUT TYPICALLY THE NEW
HOME THAT COMES IN IS DELIVER
ALL THE DEALER IS ACTUALLY
ORDERING THE HOME FROM THE
FACTORY AND PUTTING IT ON THE
SPACE AT THE DEALER IN MY
EXPERIENCE ACTUALLY PAYS A
PORTION OF THE SET UP COSTS FOR
THE SPACE INITIALLY THAT'S ALL
NEGOTIATED WITH THE PARK OWNER
THE COST TO CREATE A NEW SPACES
CERTAINLY NOTHING LIKE THE COST
CREATED YOU PARK WHERE YOU'RE
CREATING ALL THE COMMENTARY
FACILITIES OF THE ROADS SO FOR
ARE WE JUST DON'T SEE THE COST
OF THE SPACES BEING ANYTHING
INTO THAT SO I THINK THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT NOT BEING ABLE TO RECOUP
HERE IS REALLY IT'S BEEN A MESS
COMPARED TO THE AMOUNT OF
INCOME THE AMOUNT OF CASH
FLOW IT'S GOING TO BE CREATED
BY ADDING SPACES IN THE PARK
IF THAT'S WHAT THE PARKLAND
WISHES TO DO THAT I'LL SEE
THIS AS A DISINCENTIVE AT ALL
I THINK IT'S A PRETTY MINOR
COST IF YOU WILL COMPARE TO
ALL OF THE NEW CASH FLOW IT
THIS NEW SPACE WILL CREATE
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
INPUT FROM FROM BOTH SIDES
AND YOU KNOW I I JUST THINK
IN NORWAY ARE IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW THAT HE THESE PARK
OWNERS WE'VE WE'VE AND AND
AND TO SOME DEGREE RIGHTFULLY
YOU KNOW CONSTRAINED
-- WHAT THESE BUT THE PARK
OWNERS CAN DO AND YOU KNOW
I AS I STATED I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE MARKET AND THE MARKET
HOLDING SOMEBODY CAPTIVE BUT IF
SOMEBODY'S MOVING INTO THESE NEW
SPACES AND THEY KNOW THAT THEIR
WHAT THE SPACE RENTS GOING TO
BE IN THE KNOW THAT THAT SPACE
RENTS NOT GOING TO BE COVERED BY
-- BRAKE CONTROLS
YOU'VE GOT A WILLING SELLER
AND A WILLING BUYER I DON'T
KNOW WHY THE STATE WOULD
GET IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME -- SO
THANK YOU FOR EFFORT OFFICIALLY
THE CONVERSATION THANK YOU
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BOB
SEEING NONE ALL RIGHT SIR MOTION
SO I'M SORRY
MOTIONS CENTER STERN MOST THE
BILL SANDLER WAS LIKE CLOSE
YES THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST DISCUSSION AND AND
I APPRECIATE EVERYBODY THAT
TESTIFIED OF THE CORPORATE
APPRECIATE TO THREE A ROYAL
GRANDY RESIDENTS FOR MY DISTRICT
BUT -- I TESTIFIED AND I THINK
IT PLAYING OFF OF A COMMENT
THAT WAS RIGHT THERE ABOUT WISE
INTO KNOWING SELLER KNOWING
FIRE IT'S ALMOST AS IF YOU'RE
KNOWING YOU'RE GOING TO
POTENTIALLY GET INTO A HOSTAGE
SITUATION THAT IT IS NOT AS FREE
-- A MARKET A DECISION
WHEN THAT HAPPENS AND AND THERE
IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE FAIR
RATE OF RETURN TALKING ABOUT A
MINUSCULE AMOUNT I DON'T THINK
THERE WAS ANY INTENT TO WIN
THIS WAS ADOPTED IN NINETEEN
NINETY TO HAVE ANY HOUSING BUILT
SINCE THAT DATE TO THE MOBILE
HOME MORAL TO BE CALLED A NEW
IN PERPETUITY I THINK THIS
BILL ADDRESSES THAT GEN AND I
ATTEMPTED TO ADDRESS THE FAIR
RATE OF RETURN WITH THE TEN A
YEAR OF OUR EXCLUSION AT THE
BEGINNING I THINK THIS PRODUCT
PROVIDES HOUSING PROTECTION
TO PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST BUT
I VOTE SORRY THANK YOU MEANT
TO CANCEL YOU CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS SENATE BILL NINE
FORTY BY SENATOR LAYERED WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR STERN
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
AS AMENDED AMBERG HIGH --
BURKE AYE BORJAS REGIS
NOTED ASAL DRESS SO I
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG
JONES JONES NO LAYERED
LAYERED I'M MCGUIRE STERN
STERN I WAKE HOUSEKI
CAL'S SKI I WINNER WINNER
HI YOU HAVE A SIXTY TWO SO
FAR WITH SOME MEMBERS MISSING
NIGHT WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL
NEXT WE HAVE A SATELLITE
CAL SKI FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE S. B. NINE TWO EIGHT
THANK YOU MR HERE JUST JUST STOP
FOR THOSE WHO ARE LISTENING --
AFTER SAID A WHITE CAL SKI THEN
WE HAVE CENTER WILL WIENER WITH
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AND THAT
WILL BE IT WILL BE LIFTING CALLS
RIGHT THIS TOOL --
THE INCREASE THE MINIMUM FEE
THAT PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS
WHO ARE COUNTY EMPLOYEES CAN
COLLECT FROM THE STATES FROM
ONE THOUSAND TO THREE THOUSAND
STAFF REPORT DOES A GOOD JOB
EXPLAINED THAT SITUATION IS YOU
KNOW TWELVE PERCENT OF THE FEES
ARE RECOVERED BY THE COUNTY
ARE ARE THE COST TO THE COUNTY
UNLIKE ONE OF US PRACTICING
ATTORNEYS IF IT'S THE ESTATE IS
LISTED UNDER A THOUSAND DOLLARS
YOU CAN DO A ONE PAGER FILE
IT WITH THE COURT ATTACH THE
WILL AND BASICALLY ADMINISTER
THE STATE AT THE STATE OUTSIDE
THE PROBATE COURT YOU CAN'T DO
THIS THE PUBLIC MINISTRY HAVE
TO FILE A PETITION BECOME THERE
-- THE REPRESENTATIVE THE FEES
ARE GENERALLY AND INSUFFICIENT
TOOK OUT THE COVERED THE TOTAL
COST OF WHAT'S GOING ON SO THIS
HELPS ABOUT IT A LITTLE BIT --
WE HAVEN'T DONE THIS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOUR IS EXPLAINED IN
THE -- THE THE STAFF REPORT I
HAVE MISTER SMITH MISTER TRENT
SMITH WHO IS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC GARDENS
IN PUBLIC CONSERVATORS --
TO TESTIFY AND VIRGIN I VOTE
THANK YOU MR SONORA CASKEY
MISTER SMITH FLEISCHER'S
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TRANSMITS REPRESENT A
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC
CONSERVATISM PUBLIC GUARDIANS
WERE THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL
-- AS THE AUTHOR STATED IT'S
BEEN SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOUR
SINCE WE'VE INCREASED THE
SPEED AND BEFORE THAT WAS
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT SO IT'S
BEEN A LONG TIME COMING WE --
THE SENATOR WHITE HOUSE YOU
ACTUALLY INTRODUCED A BILL ON
TWENTY TWENTY -- THAT WOULD
HAVE INCREASED THE RATE AND
INCLUDED A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT -- BUT WE COULD NOT
COME UP WITH -- AN ENTITY THAT
WOULD TRIGGER -- IN DETERMINE
THE COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT
SO WE'VE COME BACK WITH THIS
BILL WE'VE INCREASED IT FROM A
THOUSAND TO THREE THOUSAND --
THE NUMBER WAS DETERMINED TO
MAKE UP FOR ALL OF THE YEARS
WHERE THERE HASN'T BEEN AN
INCREASE AND ALSO TO GIVE US
A LITTLE BIT OF CUSHION IN OUT
YEARS BECAUSE WE -- ANTICIPATE
WE WON'T BE COMING BACK EVERY
TWO YEARS OR SO TO INCREASE THIS
RATE EVEN AT THE THREE THOUSAND
DOLLAR RATE THIS IS A MONEY
LOSER FOR COUNTIES AND PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS MOST OF THESE
STATES THEY ADMINISTER THEY'RE
NEVER GOING TO COLLECT THIS
FEE AND IF THEY WERE TO COLLECT
THE THREE THOUSAND DOLLAR FEE
WOULD STILL BE WAY WAY SHORT OF
THAT MANY MANY HOURS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO ADMINISTER THESE
ESTATES SO WE WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER SMITH OTHERS
IN SUPPORT SAYING NO ONE ELSE
IN THE HEARING ROOM ON THE
PHONE LINE BUT A MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD TO UP THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE TWO EIGHT
YOUR IN SUPPORT IT IS THE
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
BUT IF SUPPORTERS SB NINE
TWENTY EIGHT ONE ONE ZERO
SO WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY
QUEUING UP HERE FOR
THE CHANCE ONE MOMENT
ONCE AGAIN THAT IS
IN PORT ONE NINE ZERO
WE WILL GO TO THE LINE
TWENTY FOUR THREE FOUR NINE
AFTERNOON CHAIR IN MEMBERS JERRY
DESMOND WITH THE PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
TWENTY EIGHT FOR THE REASONS
SET FORTH BY CENTER BY CAL SKI
AND THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
RESEARCHER WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LET'S NOT TURN TO OPPOSITION
-- DO WE HAVE ANYONE OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE HEARING WILL
SAYING NO ONE APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE -- MEMORY
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE POLICE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. NINE TWO EIGHT
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
IT IS ONE NINE ZERO
OPPOSITION ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
CAN WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION THE SWITCHER ALREADY
-- BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS SAYING
NO QUESTIONS NO NO COMMENTS
SERVICE TURN MOVES THE BILL
ACTUALLY I'M SORRY I THINK
IT DID CENTER BORJAS ACTUALLY
CENTER BOARD JUST MOVES THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR STERN ROAD ALERTING ME
THAT FACT IT FOR OUR SOMEWHERE
CAL SPEAKER CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPHONE THANK YOU
-- MAN TWO COUNTS OF YOU CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS SENATE BILL
NINE TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR BOARD JUST THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS --
BURKE HI AMBERG BY BURGESS
FOR JUSTIFIED THE RUSSELL
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ HERTZBERG
JONES JONES I LAYERED
HI LAYERED I AM MCGUIRE
STERN STERN I WAKE HOUSEKI
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER
WIENER HI RIGHT NOW IT'S
EIGHT ZERO WITH SOME MEMBERS
MISSING ALREADY THANK YOU
WILL PUT THE BILL ON HOLD
ALL RIGHT LAST BILL
CENTER WIENER EUROPE
AND IF YOU'RE WITHIN
EARSHOT OF MY VOICE
AFTER CENTER WIENER CONCLUDES
THEN WE'LL BE LIFTING CALLS
I WANT TO KNOW WHERE THE
MAJORITY LEADER AS ACTUALLY
I LIVE IN THE COUNTRY THAT'S
MY QUESTION YEAH WHERE
WHERE IS THE MAJORITY LEADER
YES -- I'M GONNA I'M GONNA PAY
FOR THE SENATE WE WERE GOING TO
STRIKE THAT FROM THE RECORD SO
OKAY -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
I'M SB THIRTY SIX SPD THIRTY SIX
SOME OF YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS
-- BECAUSE A FEW YEARS AGO --
WE PASSED I AUTHORED WE PASSED
SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE WHICH IS
GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LAW AND
WHICH ARE SADLY EXPIRED AT THE
END OF LAST YEAR AND ONE UNDER
THE RADAR THAT EXPIRATION AND
SO -- WE IDEALLY WOULD HAVE DONE
THIS BILL LAST YEAR BUT BETTER
LATE THAN NEVER WE WANT TO RE
AUTHORIZE IT -- YOU GET IT BACK
IN THE FACT WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS IT INSURES THAT -- IMMIGRANTS
IN CALIFORNIA REGARD REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS --
FEEL SAFE -- GOING TO COURT TO
TESTIFY -- AND SPECIFICALLY IT
PROVIDES THAT IF -- I WITNESSES
TESTIFYING IN COURT THEY
COULD NOT BE ASKED ABOUT THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS UNLESS THE
ATTORNEY HAS FIRST HELD AN
IN CAMERA HEARING -- WITH THE
COURT -- TO SHOW WHY IMMIGRATION
STATUS IS RELEVANT TO THE
CASE AND IF IT'S RELEVANT ON
THE QUESTION CAN BE ASKED --
BUT WE WILL FOR THIS WILL NOT
ALLOW A LAWYER LAWYERS JUSTICE
TO RANDOMLY ASKING AWARENESS
ABOUT IMMIGRATION STATUS WHICH
CAN BE A FORM OF HARASSMENT
-- AND CAN ALSO -- -- BECAUSE
FEAR IN IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES
-- IF YOU'RE THERE TO GO TO
COURT YOU'RE GONNA BE ASKED
ABOUT YOUR IMMIGRATION STATUS
AND THAT MIGHT RESULT IN YOU
BEING DEPORTED WE KNOW THAT IN
THE LAST ADMINISTRATION -- THERE
WERE I USE -- OUR
AGENTS IN CALIFORNIA COURTS
-- AND THE LAST THING WE WANT
IS FOR PEOPLE TO BE FEARFUL
TO GO TO COURT WE WILL WE WANT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMS OF
CRIME OR WHO ARE WITNESSES --
TO TO GO TO COURT AND TESTIFY
-- IF THEY BELIEVE THEY'RE
GOING TO GET SUPPORT THAT GOING
TO COURT TESTIFIED WILL RESULT
IN THE DEPORTATION THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO GO AND WE WILL ALL
BE LESS SAFE AS A RESULT --
SO THIS IS A -- COMMONSENSE --
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS -- WITH ME --
TESTIFYING TODAY'S DENTAL SADO
FROM THE LOS ANGELES DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE ONE OF OUR
CO SPONSORS -- AND RESEARCH
DíAS FROM LEGAL AID AT WORK
THANK YOU CENTER WINNER
-- MISTER I THOUGHT THE
THE SHERMAN MEMBERS STAND
FELIZ ALL ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE ARE PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION
PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE OF SB
EIGHTY FIVE IT WAS QUITE
COMMON FOR DEFENSE COUNSEL TO
ASK OF ME WITNESSES OR VICTIMS
IMMIGRATION STATUS THE POINT
OF DOING SO WAS TO TRY AND
DISSUADE THEM FOR PARTICIPATING
IN THE CRIMINAL COURTS PROCESS
THIS IS SENATOR MENTIONED
DURING THE LAST ADMINISTRATION
THERE WAS A FEAR OF
A MASS -- REMOVAL
PROCESS THAT WAS GOING TO
BEGIN BECAUSE OF THOSE
TWO FACTORS THERE WAS A
CHILLING EFFECT ON OUR COURT
SYSTEM AND PARTICULARLY
OUR CRIMINAL COURT SYSTEM
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS ARE
WE'RE LESS LIKELY TO WANT TO
COOPERATE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
BECAUSE OF FEAR THAT DOING
SO COULD LEAD TO THEIR
REMOVAL FROM THIS COUNTRY
I CAN TELL YOU IT NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS AS A PROSECUTOR AND
POLICE OFFICER IN CALIFORNIA
THE UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION
IS FAR MORE LAW ABIDING
THAN THE GENERAL POPULATION
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A FEAR OF
COMING IN CONTACT WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT I CAN ALSO TELL YOU
THAT THE UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION
IS FAR MORE LIKELY TO BE
VICTIMS OF CRIME THAN THE
GENERAL POPULATION PERSONALLY
BECAUSE OF THAT FEAR OF
COOPERATING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHEN YOU HAVE WITNESSES
AND VICTIMS AFRAID TO COME
TO COURT WHAT THAT DOES
IS EMBOLDEN THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THE TARGET THIS POPULATION
KNOWING THAT THERE ARE FAR
MORE LIKELY TO GET AWAY WITH
IT BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
COOPERATE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
I'VE WORKED AS A PROSECUTOR
IN LOS ANGELES FOR NEARLY TWENTY
YEARS I WAS A POLICE OFFICER
SAN FRANCISCO BEFORE THAT
THE FEAR IN THESE
COMMUNITIES IS VERY REAL AND
HAVING SB SIX SEVENTY FIVE
UNINTENTIONALLY SUNSET
IT'S GOING TO LEAD TO MORE
VICTIMIZATION THE HIGHER CRIME
RATES IF WE DON'T REENACT
THESE PROTECTIONS WHILE THESE
PROTECTIONS WERE IN PLACE AT
A TOTALLY BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
RECORD KEEPING BUT I CHECKED
WITH PROSECUTORS OFFICES AND
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS AROUND THE
STATE MASS WERE YOU AWARE
OF ANY SITUATION WHERE A
MATERNITY HAD TO BE DISCIPLINED
BECAUSE OF VIOLATING THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS LAW AND
AND NOBODY COULD FIND ANY
THE MERE FACT THAT THE STATUTE
EXISTS DID WHAT WE WANTED TO DO
ELIMINATED THE UNNECESSARY
QUESTIONING ABOUT IMMIGRATION
STATUS NOW I CAN TELL YOU THERE
ARE A HANDFUL OF CRIMES IN
CALIFORNIA THE ONLY UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS CAN BE THE VICTIM
THERE ARE CERTAIN DEFENSES THAT
HASN'T UNDOCUMENTED YOU WOULD
HAVE AND SO IN THOSE CASES
QUESTIONING IMMIGRATION STATUS
IS RELEVANT AND IS AUTHORIZED
UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF S. B.
SEVENTY FIVE AND IN THIS BILL
THIS BILL ALSO DOES NOT PRECLUDE
A DEFENDANT TO THE PETITIONER
FROM VOLUNTARILY DISCLOSING
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS
THOSE PROTECTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
IN BOTH LAW AND THEN THEY
WERE CLOSED FOR GOOD REASON
BUT LIKE I SAY I CAN TELL
YOU BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE
AND I'M FORTUNATELY WORKING
IN LOS ANGELES WORKING AS
SAM SISCO I'VE COME ACROSS
AND WORK WITH UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITIES CONTINUOUSLY
THEY ARE VICTIMIZED THEY ARE
AFRAID AND HAVING
THIS PROTECTION IN PLACE WILL
NOT END VICTIMIZATION WILL NOT
AND THAT FEAR BUT IT WILL HELP
IT DID HELP IT IS URGENT
THAT YOU PLEASE REINSTATE
THIS PROCESS TO PROTECT SOME
OF THE MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU
THANK YOU FIVE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT SAYING NO ONE ELSE
IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING
OH YES ONE OTHER IN SUPPORT
ADVERSITY IS HARDLY EVER
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CALL
I'M ON THE PHONE LINES
IT'S HARD TO SAY YES YES
IS THIS GO HEAD THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME MANY VIDEOS
AND I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL
AID AT WORK A NONPROFIT LEGAL
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES FOR
THE RIGHTS OF LOW WAGE WORKERS
I WANTED TO BE HERE TODAY HAVE
AN ORGANIZATIONAL CO SPONSOR
AND TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT THIRTY SIX
I ALSO WANT TO THANK SENATOR
WIENER FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
SB THIRTY SIX WILL ENSURE
IMMIGRATION STATUS INFORMATION
CANNOT BE USED AS A TOOL OF
INTIMIDATION BUT WHICH STILL
ACTIVE PRODUCTIVE FOR THE
MILLIONS OF IMMIGRANTS WHO
CALIFORNIANS HOMES AT THE
CALIFORNIA COURT OF APPEALS
HAS RECOGNIZED CALIFORNIA LAWS
ALREADY ON THE BOOKS LEAVING NO
ROOM FOR DOUBT ABOUT THIS STATE
PUBLIC POLICY WITH REGARD TO THE
RELEVANT OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
ENFORCEMENT OF STATE LABOR
EMPLOYMENT AND A VARIETY OF
OTHER LOT DESPITE DEVELOPMENT
THAT IMMIGRATION STATUS TO
AN EMPLOYER'S LIABILITY UNDER
CALIFORNIANS EMPLOYMENT MON
IN OUR WORK WE SEE EMPLOYERS
TO OFTEN ATTEMPT TO DISCOVER
AND LOTUS THAT IS THROUGH THE
LITIGATION PROCESS THE WAY OF
DETERRING WORKERS FROM ASSERTING
THEIR RIGHT FOR EXAMPLE WERE
CURRENTLY INVOLVED IN THE CASE
THAT WAS BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
AN IMMIGRANT WORKER WHO HAD
WORKED FOR YOUR EMPLOYER FOR
MORE THAN TEN YEARS ONLY TO BE
TERMINATED DAYS AFTER EXERCISING
HIS WORKERS COMPENSATION
RATES SHRINK DISCOVERY THE
EMPLOYER THOUGHT INTRUSIVE AND
IRRELEVANT IMMIGRATION STATUS
INFORMATION SH THE NINTH CIRCUIT
HAS RECOGNIZED THAT THESE
TYPE OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
INCREASE ALLOW EMPLOYERS TO
RAISE IMPLICITLY THE THREAT
OF DEPORTATION AND CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION EVERY TIME A WORKER
DOCUMENTED OR UNDOCUMENTED
FILED AN EMPLOYMENT ACTION
THIS IS THE SAME PER DISCLOSURE
THAT THE STATUS IN OPEN COURT
IN EITHER INSTANCE CARUTHERS
COUNTLESS ACTS OF ILLEGAL AND
REPREHENSIBLE CONDUCT TO GO
UNREPORTED SB EIGHT THIRTY SIX
WILL ENSURE THAT WORKERS AND
OTHER CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS AN ACTIVE
ACCORD IN THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL FOR THE ROBUST
ENFORCEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
EMPLOYMENT AND CIVIL RIGHTS
LAWS FOR THESE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MYSTERIOUS FATHERS IN SUPPORT
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM PLEASE
BRIDGE MIKE FONG GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS -- CAN LYING ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION PROUD
BECAUSE SPONSORED THE BILL AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU OTHERS IN THE HEARING
ROOM SEEING NO ONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE LINE BEEN A MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD TWO OF THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT THREE SIX
IF YOU ARE IMPORTED
ONE VENDOR THE ROLE ON
YOUR PHONE IN SUPPORT
WE HAVE ROUGHLY FIVE
PEOPLE IN QUEUES HERE IN
SUPPORT IT'LL GO TO WINE
FIFTY FOUR THREE FOUR NINE
YES GOOD AFTERNOON
THERE ARE TERRORISTS
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW GO TO
NINE EIGHTY IN LINE ET YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THE DOCUMENT
FOR ON BEHALF OF THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU
YEAH LEVINE NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT
REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NINE EIGHTY ONE THE LINE IS OPEN
KAREN COMMITTEE MEMBER JOHNNY
YOU KNOW THAT THE COALITION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHT
IT'S A PROBLEM COSPONSORED
SB EIGHT THIRTY P. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE ROUGHLY
THREE WALKING CUTE HERE
WE HAVE ONE FIFTEEN
MY NUMBER KICKING YOUR OPEN
ON THE COPIER GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
SORRY THIS IS NOT AGAIN RATHER
THAN ENOUGH BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT IN FAVOR OF EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
TWO EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANK YOU I THINK THAT
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP AND
MET THE BALANCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
ONE MORE IN CULINARY
INCLINED THAT NUMBER EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
HELLO THIS IS BRANDON POLLOCK
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SPENDING
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SUMMER STEPHAN OUR OFFICE
IS IN SUPPORT OF F. P. EIGHT
THREE SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYMORE IN
CUBA CIRCA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET'S TURN THE OPPOSITION
UP FIRST LET ME WELCOME
MAJORITY LEADER MCGUIRE THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY --
ALL RIGHT --
ANYONE ELSE IT OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM NOT SAYING NONE OF
C. SEEING BUT NOT IN THE ROOM
-- DURING THE PHONE LINES
FOR OPPOSITION WHAT KIND
-- YOUR IN OPPOSITION AT
EIGHT THIRTY THAT IS ONE NINE
ZERO -- THE OPPOSITION THE
ONE ZERO SIX CASUALTIES
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY QUEUING
UP THE STRUCTURE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- SINGLE OPPOSITION
ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE SINISTER AND MOVES THE
BILL SIR WHAT COUNTS THE
WAYS OF THE BILL -- ALL RIGHT
-- SEVEN WILL WOULD YOU CARE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIGHT OF ART THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MAN CHIEF COUNSEL IF
YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL THIS
IS SENATE BILL EIGHT THIRTY
SIX BY SENATOR WIENER WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR STERN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS -- BURKE
AMBERG I BOARD JESS DID ASAL
THE REST SO I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
JONES JONES NOT VOTING
LAYERED BY LAYERED I'D
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE STERN
STERN HIGHWAY CAL SKI
BY CAL SKI HI WIENER HI
WIENER HI YOU HAVE A MEMBER
MISSING IN THE VOTE IS OUT SORRY
THE R. FIVE SIXTY SEVEN EIGHTY
OF NINE RIGHT NOW NINE --
THE BILL IS OUT I BELIEVE
THAT'S FINAL SO IS THE LIVING
ROOM -- ALL RIGHT THE BILLS
OUT OKAY ALL RIGHTS NINETY
ZERO SO MANAGE TO COUNSEL IF
YOU WOULD OPEN THE ROLE ON ALL
THE BILLS ON CALL ABSOLUTELY
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
DO THAT WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI
DURACELL DURACELL HI
HERTZBERG THIS IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI
MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE STERN
STERN BY WHITE HOUSE
E. Y. CASKEY FIVE
THIS ELEVEN TO ZERO WITH
ALL MEMBERS VOTING CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
AT THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE BYE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS WICKS AND GRAYSON
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI
THAT'S TEN TO ONE
AND THAT'S ALL MEMBERS
VOTING BY BILLS OUT
THE NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX THIS IS THE SENATE
RESOLUTION FORTY FIVE BY
SENATOR MAN WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING PICTURE OUT THE CHAIR
READING THE CHAIR VOTING I
REGIS THE RUSSELL
THE REST SO I JONES
I'M SORRY WHICH ONE THIS IS
FILE ITEMS SIX -- SR
FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR MEN
JONES JONES NOT VOTING
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE HI
STERN STERN AYE WIENER
WIENER HI THAT'S
NINE TWO ZERO
BILLS OUT RESOLUTION IS OUT
RESOLUTION -- S. J. R.
TWELVE IS FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI S.
J. R. TWELVE BY SENATOR SKINNER
CHAIR READING AYE BORJAS
DURACELL DURACELL HI JONES
NUMBER JONES NOT VOTING
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
STERN STERN HI
THAT'S NINE TWO ZERO
OF RESOLUTIONS OUT THE
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG S. B.
NINE THIRTEEN WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING HI DID ASAL
AYE DRESSEL AYE JONES
I'M SORRY IT'S THAT'S
OKAY FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE SENATOR HERTZBERG S.
B. NINE ONE THREE YES
OKAY JONES HI
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE STERN
STERN STERN HI THAT'S ELEVEN
TWO ZERO MEMBERS VOTING
SO THAT'S ELEVEN TO
ZERO WITH ALL MEMBERS VOTING
THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN S. B. NINE
FORTY BY SENATOR LAYERED
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG NOT VOTING
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
THAT'S EIGHT TWO TWO TWO
ALL MEMBERS VOTING FILLS
OUT SINCE THE LAST ITEM
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI
THAT'S S. B. NINE TWENTY
EIGHT WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ BY HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE THAT'S ELEVEN TWO ZERO
WITH ALL MEMBERS VOTING BILL
IS OUT OF BELIEVES UNDER STERN
BELOW CONSENT CONSENT CONSENT
BUT DOUBLE CHECK YOUR FOR
THEIR OWN YES YOU VOTED FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SORRY
WE ARE ADJOURNED UNTIL NEXT
TUESDAY WHEN WE HAVE BEEN
ONCE WELCOMED DONE